[Music]
metformin Cheers Cheers
I know for what it's worth I know
everything I'm a witch
are you a witch are you a witch I think
you think I I am
first of all I just want to start by
saying yeah that I am if I'm coming off
cool and composed at all yeah it's only
because my mom died three days ago
I'm incredibly you're gonna make me cry
in all of you
and have been a huge fan
um
as for as long as I've known that I was
going to attempt to do comedy I've
looked up to you and used to
um
like if I had a spot at the comic store
and I knew you were at the Laugh Factory
if you were just like in town like
you're one of the few Comics I would
like go watch as a comic because other
Comics I was like no no don't like I
knew with a tell I saw so many people
like doing a tell not doing a towel not
stealing just like being influenced by
and I was so afraid to be to copy anyone
or like yeah but I would watch you
um
so I'm very intimidated by you really
uh-huh this past skank Fest my first
skank Fest ever I just came in to just
do a day yeah I think I've always been
too scared to actually say yes to doing
it yeah
um because I don't think I'd earned the
right to perform for them yet maybe
um or to be um
you know I did a legion of skanks maybe
like four or five months ago and then
after that I felt like okay like well
you know I was supposed to be on that
show I when you went at skank Fest Vegas
when you went up on the skank show I was
supposed to go on that show like I had
to I was getting a tattoo I had been
watching you yeah another stage oh like
two hours before yeah so I was getting
my tattoo I had to run over to do that
but I came and saw you on stage
and you were fucking killing it you guys
were having a blast like the place was
going nuts so the guy was like Hey you
and I was like dude let this happen
I am I go let this happen right now
because this is fucking going because
because this will make sure Whitney
loses everything in five years in a
lawsuit keep rolling on her fingering
this man on stage it was evidence but it
was so funny it was so funny to see you
up there just fucking hanging having fun
and everybody everybody was dying I mean
it was you guys were killing I thought
it was hilarious so I didn't go up there
and because I didn't want to get
canceled either I didn't want to be
associated with this no such thing as
cancer you know of course yes cancel
this for acting actors get canceled
Comics don't get canceled correct yeah
we can't get canceled okay yeah getting
canceled is the best way to find out
about a comic you didn't know about
before I want to get canceled like I get
jealous when like Shane or Louis was at
a club before me and there was
protesters and I get nothing I just get
middle-aged couples going looking
forward to see you Bob can't wait for
the show go to babysitter it's not
outrage that I'm destroying our youth
fuck I fucking love I fucking I know
when people don't think that I'm like
hurting women and setting women back I'm
like oh
I feel the same way I want to be hurting
women instead of women back and now
let's not be like clever enough I guess
I'm just Beloved the Beloved
embarrassing it is embarrassing we're
like we're like hair bands and they're
punk rock I know I'm like wait hold on
The Tonight Show just doesn't even want
to see my set they're going to let me
just come on they think I'm not like you
could just do it yeah so I'm just
welcome anything you can do The Tonight
Show that's fucking nuts they don't even
want to see my set first that's how
bland and they think I am no I haven't I
haven't done this answer in ages but I
want to hit my wife I want to get
someone stop hitting there by the way
she'll be able to dodge it I'm not
worried about her she's from Boston not
worried about her we actually got into a
fight once where I I hit her
um not intentionally yeah I uh I threw
chicken I had raw chicken and we got
into a big fight about barbecuing or
whatever then I fucking went fuck
Chicken in L.A when we lived in L.A and
I was trying to throw it off the balcony
onto Sepulveda and uh it slipped halfway
and slapped her in the fucking face and
then slid down her cheek and she went
you motherfucker
whatever damage you did you'd have to
put the cold chicken back on to ice it
she fucking good for inflammation a
sharp ball up a fist and a nail popped
off and then I had to hold her down with
all my weight and she kept I'm holding
it down she kept going smiling which is
creepy she's going kid call me kid kid
get off me fucking kid I swear to God
kid I'm like baby I fucked up I love you
I love you stop calling me kid it's
scaring the shit out of me that's it was
like fighting Matt James from Goodwill
Hunting so it's like did you ever see
the chain changeling no it's a movie
with Angelina Jolie it takes place in
the 20s based on a true story where
there was a pedophile that was stealing
children and and chopping them up with a
shovel molesting them I didn't mean to
laugh no you shouldn't it's pretty
hilarious like because also back then in
the 20s children were pedophiles were so
like they were so dirty back then they
were like uncircumcised like to molest a
kid in the 20s you had to like pull back
like dirty uncircumcised never mind kids
dirty dicks too
bad okay yeah little tiny uncircumcised
dirty dicks like mud dicks like if
you're a pedophile in 2022 like you
really were a pedophile
in the 20s like you were like I'm
willing to get now it's 11 leprosy I'm
willing to get gangrene the chickenpox
that's how much I love baby dicks I'm
gonna get measles amazing whereas now if
you're a pedophile you're like well how
do I know how hard you I mean the kids
are vaccinated wear a mask like it's a
pretty safe bet right get it all
circumcised yeah exactly perfect little
peckers yeah it's so much easier now and
so there's not as many risks so the
pedophiles back then
you know so anyway the movie it was a
golden age of being a pedophile was
probably well think about it the 20s
when they were working in factories how
easy was that chicken in a barrel 1900s
fish in a barrel fish in a barrel yeah
you had me on this question about you I
think the 1900s and so it had to be the
80s no 90s
or 80s when they got cameras when like
security cameras yeah and like like
everybody had a social security number
that and a license plate because it was
a time I mean you could just drive a car
but you got please don't tell me you got
molested and of course I got molested by
I'm insulted you think I was molested do
you think you think I was an ugly kid
but what I'm saying no I don't I mean
I've been molested too but I'm saying by
you're raising your hand but because I
just want to say yes before the 1800s
let's say the life expectancy was what
38.
so if someone was a pedophile was there
any way to go like well they just
weren't sure if oh the age kind of
shrunk they might go like I don't know
how much longer this person's gonna live
yeah because the life expectancy yeah I
think you got married at 15 too so is
that was that that's wasn't a pedophile
back then that was just a good business
person well yeah you might you might
have got away with it back then yeah I
mean you're out in the middle of nowhere
and it's like look nobody's here we're
gonna die in a couple as long as you
procreated and made a kid you probably
got away with it yeah exactly okay sorry
but I didn't mean you got you didn't get
molested by a pedophile
I did look older than I was okay all
right you might have thought I was older
I was seven he probably thought I was 18
sure
this is such a fucked up right you only
get blessed once she you are just uh
insult after insult with this guy I get
it you hate L.A comments I don't I love
you molested little Comics so
um I Made Me Stronger thanks buddy
um okay first of all so I am intimidated
by you I'm I'm gonna be a little awkward
with you I do have a couple orders of
business please let's do it and I don't
I I don't know why you're intimidated
I'm in your house you could kill me
just delete the tape nobody knows I'm
here the tape the tape that's it but
you're right that you you're you know
what I'll take that one the tape I'll
take that one 100 the beta mag I have
taken it three times now I would take it
one more time and then I'm done taking
it because you're 100 right that's a
good fucking tape go ahead
I knew I got your wife gifts for a
reason I knew she she deserved oh she's
gonna love you the frankincense and
myrrh offerings because
um so I am a psycho fan to the point of
being a little bit creepy okay
um watching your special last night kill
box I just want to be very clear with
everyone it's not don't panic you're
going to go to Louis ck.com yeah don't
panic and don't panic now you're not
going to do anything to you no a Dick's
not going to be shown to you on the
first page it doesn't go the thing and
then a dick pop the dick doesn't just
pop up yeah and if it does it's not Luis
no it's not okay there's you know those
I think those days are over
unfortunately okay I never got to see it
I didn't either he never showed it to me
right bummed out it's it's just rude but
it's fine like I think he like you know
I it's fine one time I watched him eat
some pie
which is very similar yeah so Louis is
now brilliantly having specials on his
website he you know this is the thank
God yeah Comics are just going you know
what why not me why don't we just do it
so that we're not doing see-so in Comedy
Central and all these nightmares of a
bunch of business people that fraternity
guys that can't do comedy and can't do
anything so like I'll just be run a
Comedy Network and then they're deciding
who you know yeah so those days are over
Louis ck.com they have Apple pay when I
tell you it took even if it takes you 10
minutes it's worth it but it took me all
I had to do was hit Apple pay downloaded
it watched it it's right on my quick
time right here and then you can put up
just trying to make everyone not panic
right because when people go I know it's
not on Netflix it's not on HBO Max
that's because it's funny
they don't have that's where the right
so just go to louisck.com and then
you're gonna get it you're gonna pay for
it yeah because it's worth it
the ones that are for free aren't as
funny that's why they're free
are we done are we can I move on
watch that I am so fucking jealous of
this special it is
I was I literally paused it and had to
like go for a couple like walks around
the house are you the best thank you so
much I'm not no I'm I it pains me to say
and
um I'd listen to your podcast I was
listening this morning yeah and last
night yeah your podcast may I ask how
long you've been doing it you know what
dude it's called you know what dude I've
been doing it I I probably started when
um
before Marin and Burr and you taught me
how to do a podcast I just started
listening like to your podcast the last
couple days and I'm like oh this is what
I'm I've never known how to do a podcast
I have no idea what I'm doing and I
listened to yours and I was like oh
you just say what you think without an
agenda and respond I've seen your
podcast I think you 100 know what you're
doing you're fucking great you're great
you you you you fucking keep it going
you're funny you have something to say
and yeah thank you I think you're crazy
I love it I think I've been a little
like you know like my mom just died I've
had 12 years of like in my real estate
in my brain I haven't had full bandwidth
to be present I don't feel like I've
ever been present yeah since my mom was
sick like she's been in a bed and you're
always kind of the back of your mind
thinking like oh my mom's just staring
at a wall you know she had a stroke and
then her brain was all there but her
body didn't move so I think I've always
just been in like a rush because I
always thought it was the day my mom's
gonna die so it's like I kind of
interrupt people I kind of like try too
hard like you know I'm too manic because
I'm so insecure I'm not funny enough I'm
not being interesting enough my business
fear of life's being boring blah blah
anyway so
listener podcast the great Sacramento is
on who just worked on the rest with us
which you know yeah one of the most
brilliant comedy Minds I've ever run
past I wrote in roast rooms for
I don't know four or five years for The
Comedy Central roast then I did them and
then I've always you know written jokes
Zak Amico he's he's not only that but
he's also the most gentlest kindest
comic I've ever met I think that when
you're that good you don't need to be
aggressive
yeah he's a I mean I love when I first
met him I was like oh fuck this guy's
gonna be a problem the sweetest guy I've
ever met I love him I love him he uh
this is a list of his jokes
um people never sleep on Dave Attell
probably because the only memorable
thing he's ever done was Insomniac it's
like I can just like anything I'm just
pulling up random emails about after Big
Jay oakerson but enough about tons of
Anarchy
it's just every single I'm just picking
these randomly yeah he's uh Bert filmed
his last specials in spirituals bird
filmed his last specials in Philadelphia
Cleveland and now Omaha Nebraska Bert
can you only tape specials in cities
where there's enough people fatter than
you yeah sorry I interrupted you
Big Jay would never have sex with a girl
the same age or younger than his
daughter if he could remember how old
his daughter was
he's targeted he's two things he's the
sweetest guy in the world and he's the
most one of the most vicious meanest
Minds in comedy like he thinks of
terrible terrible things and he laughs
at it but he's the kindest dude ever but
the kindest because what we do here the
insulting each other yeah
the kindest way to do it is have the
most thoughtful well-constructed insult
yeah the only way to be mean with us is
to be sloppy about it yep and you know
because then you're not giving someone
the respect of a funny insult yeah
you're insulting them with like a sloppy
you know what I mean like this we can
take it we're just being mean yes it's
like if you're gonna stab someone make
the knife super sharp so it doesn't hurt
as much yeah like I remember Jesus
making fun of me at the seller one night
and everybody was laughing and I just
went yeah well you get fucking diabetes
he was like Bobby I do have diabetes
what are you doing that's just mean I'm
fucking diabetic you piece of shit I was
like I'm sorry I didn't think it through
I just got hurt
now's not the time I think for us to
talk about
my I shouldn't weigh in on Patrice I
love that story but I do think he was
sometimes a little meaner than he had to
have been well here's the thing where is
it maybe here's the thing it was mean
and it's fine it was an honor to have
Patrice have been mean to me but at the
end of it at the when he was if you look
at Patrice at the end he was actually
figuring out
how to coexist so his theory was this
instead of me being uncomfortable around
you I'd rather you be uncomfortable but
I'm a comic I'm already uncomfortable
right you know but you don't think like
that you don't have to do that to other
Comics right he doesn't think like that
yeah he you know when he went in a room
instead of me walking into being
uncomfortable I'm gonna make all you
fucks be uncomfortable but towards the
end he actually started changing that
and becoming even with the industry
becoming a little nicer and a little a
little more like I don't have to do that
shit anymore which yeah you know is is
sad but I think my next level of like
you know and being in like grief you
know it'll really help and like
forgiveness like we forget about this
not because they deserve forgiveness
because we deserve peace but I think I
just like it's my ego that I guess I
needed or wanted Patrice to like me or
like respect me and I hadn't earned that
respect I walked up to him dubbed Dave
and AV and I were
really close and it was in LA and you
know Patrice putting myself in patrice's
shoes Patrice is on the patio at The
Comedy Store everyone's unctuous with
him he's like the you know everyone
probably wants something from him his
attention his approval whatever and I
went up and said hi to Dove and yes he
probably felt my motive my motive was
I'm gonna go meet Patrice O'Neal oh my
God you know I was
25. what do you do it was so small right
and I just thought like I'm a fan of
this guy I'm gonna go pay my respect to
him I don't know if he knew I was a
comic or not now looking back there's a
strong chance he wouldn't have known but
Dove I would have expected Dove to tell
him but why would they be talking about
me and that's what do you do I went up
to dub and I was like hi how are you and
then I was like Patrice I was like hi my
name's Whitney Cummings I just want to
let you know I'm a huge fan I'm Whitney
and he just went okay
it was just like and then just like
which is funny it is funny but he just
looked at me like okay like okay let me
tell you something it's better than what
Rich Voss did to me when I came to New
York which I knew him from Boston as a
young comic and I walked up in front of
the bar in front of everybody how long
you been doing comedy I've been doing it
for five or six years go get me a cup of
coffee Two Sugars and everybody laughed
at me and I was like yeah fuck yourself
you know what I mean
um testing you to just but then you can
just go no right wasn't the idea to say
no and then you pass the test no I mean
I don't know but I mean I just made you
a coffee fuck him you know what I mean I
just made you a coffee and you'd didn't
ask me to what's worse no I did ask you
to I wanted iced coffee you said you
wanted one and you and you gave me well
you didn't can we stop though you really
didn't make it
I poured it you poured it out of a thing
ordered it and that's then today's
version of making it I mean I mean yeah
I didn't grow the beans no well you
could have I mean you could I'm just
saying I thank you it's awesome coffee
but you just poured it out of a thing
but you said jump I said how high you
did you did it was good coffee it's
fantastic coffee I gave you my last
Stevia you know was he the last one I
feel bad about that but listen here's
the thing I think that the age when we
came up
it's so comedy's such a fucking weird
we're egomaniacs with infrared and
complexes I'm a piece of shit in the
center of the universe it's like you
gotta go on stage after these
motherfuckers just murdered and there's
so many intense situations you know
whether the industries in the crowd or
at a certain club or who went up before
you who's going up after you and you got
to go up and you gotta have this
confidence to go the fuck up and own
that room and do what you do and in the
back end I'm a hack my shit stinks
they're better than me that judging me
but and they're doing the same thing but
also you're the motherfucker and then
you're gonna go sit at that table or
somewhere with them in a green room and
kind of own your space when we're all
coming from fucking abuse and all that
we're coming from terrible shit that's
why we're able to do this and then we
have no we've done no help
but we're just we're literally white
knuckling this shit for the first 15
years and then for me like the maybe the
last five
and I was like look man I ain't gonna
make it I ain't gonna make it here I
ain't gonna have a family I can have
friends I have to figure this shit out I
have to go back and I gotta fuck I am
I'm I'm a I'm a recovering alcoholic and
drug addict first sober 18 at 18 right
36 or 15. I'm sorry 15 years that I'm
numb that's first right also if I may
say if we don't get to it all just
interject uh uh Bobby on Joe Rogan what
three weeks ago around a month ago made
me cry I mean it is such an unbelievable
story it's like it's like what that
Pursuit of Happiness Will Smith movie
like thought it was doing like it's so
inspiring it's so heartwarming and the
way that you talk about your recovery
and the the mentor that you had that
helped you stay so like it's just must
listen it's like that thing though like
I feel like now
you realize okay I I I got it I did
whatever the fuck it was I was supposed
to do but now it's time to take care of
the relationships in my life like now
now that we're in the relationships with
the right people we I was busy taking
care of a lot of relationships that
didn't need nurturing because they
shouldn't have been because we don't
know anybody we don't know we don't know
it's like maybe if I let this person go
is that wrong if I keep this person like
I love the fact that just let them go
like let people go once they fall out
let them fall for now they can always
Circle back and grow and change or
integrate or you know so I think that
it's like for me I agree case-by-case
basis I think one of the biggest
struggles in life we have is when we
just hold on too tight to things that
aren't meant for us you know 100 and
something that you know the the I I'm
big on adages and aphorisms not because
I think they're you know smart just
because they rhyme but it helps my type
of brain
I do well I'm gonna have to re-listen to
this and go back in adages and images
ravages I don't even know what the fuck
is happening I just nodded I took a sip
it was just like like a fortune cookie
what the fuck is the first one what's an
attitude an adage is like a it works
what's the second one aphorism aphorism
is that an affirmation
you're too smart this is what you know
what I just learned about you walking in
your house
you're highly intelligent
I mean the first you know you are
everyone thinks I'm so dumb you're not I
can't like it I like that everyone
thinks I'm dumb you're not and I I
didn't think you were dumb but I didn't
think you were a smart smart you're very
smart aphorism a pithy observation that
contains a general truth such as if it
ain't broke don't fix it okay well what
doesn't kill you makes you stronger
that's one of my favorite words piffy
pithy pithy pithy and package
package what's feckless is when you're
reckless you're just like a sloppy
person I'm very feckless backless
motherfucker no you're not you could but
I am but it's smart to say that I'm very
feckless So Adam peckish thank you for
the half a banana though do you want
okay good well that's where your package
you only had half yeah I only can eat
half but it's good because of my my face
it gives us some energy to not be
totally full but let me um two things so
I'm fascinated because I think that a
big part of what getting whatever I have
is and this was not intended I worked
really hard to try to convince people I
was smart yeah but I think that people
under arrested me so so much for so long
that that it actually so just for people
out there listening if you're not
getting the respect you think you
deserve like it's okay because being
underestimated I think on some way kind
of helped me I don't know how and number
two I'll say one more thing which is
that on your podcast that I was
listening to
um
addictively
you mentioned that you think I have
llamas and I was just curious yes where
that there's a lot of I saw you in
llamas in on a uh yeah I I follow you on
fucking Instagram on social media and
you had a fucking llama am I crazy no
well I did I don't own it but so
sometimes people can be around animals
they don't own like there's far you know
what I mean so so I mean I'm happy
listen to me I love that you think
anything I'm near is mine
well look I you treated it like it was
your last Instagram he's a he's in a
fucking farm with his kids and Nia it
doesn't mean he has goats but he has a
fuck I mean he has certain things
helicopter that's nuts that is nuts
that's nuts that is nuts but Bill Burr
is like Eileen the drum kit my
helicopter and a fucking old neurotic I
trust that he would never fly that thing
like Kobe's guy oh no trouble Kobe's guy
flew he because he was probably start
didn't want to say no to Kobe Bryant
who's not a helicopter pilot he's a
basket well great not a helicopter great
but the
lafd was was I'm sorry LAPD was grounded
why are you flying with lapds grounded
because you know more than they do right
I I don't know I think you're right but
I don't know why are you flying kids uh
when lapd's grounded yeah you should
what are we in the rush for basketball
game I think they would go will they go
into a basketball game no not his best
for the kids yeah which is that's crazy
yeah cancel the game you're gonna watch
your kids talk at basketball anyway
let's still skip that game we don't
either yeah it drives me not to but that
happened literally two haulers away
ahala
I'm sorry so we live in them I'm sorry
mountains so a holler a hollow you know
the Holloway is like a sleepy yeah it's
like a Sleepy Hollow it's like a dip in
Two Mountains right you know so it's
like two of those that happened in
Calabasas oh yeah no shit collar so now
can I ask you a question sure I'm sorry
no no you go well the other thing yeah
well you so you don't have llamas I
don't have llamas but where my horse is
so I've rested you have a horse yeah I
rescue I mean that's close all right
it's very close they're incredibly
different animals a llama can't really a
llamas is very helpful for protection
and defense for what for coyotes no shit
coyotes are sorry llamas are incredibly
aggressive I didn't know they're scary
as shit well they have to think about
how vulnerable they are so the more
vulnerable you are as an animal the more
vicious you'd have to be to protect
yourself so they've got this neck that's
right out there that's a weird answer
they spit very Dr Sue
yeah and the way they kind of walk yeah
I have a friend and living with Pickles
you guys know where she's I rescue with
her and she has a llama that lives in
her house with her and it's so wild it's
like wait a minute lives in the house
she has a llama that lives but doesn't
the Llama just pee in the house uh no
it's house trained what you can train
him you can train a llama to pee outside
I see that just blows me you might not
be able to but a patient someone uh with
patience so the Llama will never poo or
pee in the house he'll like go out does
your llama a llama door so
um it just know she just opens the door
that's a crazy looking animal too it's
crazy they're cool and has frosted tips
just like her so cool that's wild yeah
so she's so there's you know animals are
incredible
um the right ones uh especially since I
kind of live in in the middle of nowhere
um uh mini donkeys are great uh and to
defend against coyotes and predators and
also peacocks because when a peacock
sees a predator they freak out and they
fly up into the trees you know if
they're flying up into the trees yeah
these peacocks are frightening the noise
they make is frightening so prey animals
are just incredibly good at
communicating that there's danger you
know so they're good to have I worked in
a farm in juvenile juvenile where
um Upstate New York they had me uh one
summer
they were like you have to go to this
job uh and work five I work five days a
week was it animals it was a it was um
it was an animal farm for kids okay so I
would have to go there at like seven in
the morning or 6 30 not a pedophile ring
and no no pedophiles it was actually run
by uh Michael Jackson's um
had animals it was run by a lesbian no
one found that weird uh my boss was a
big lesbian very tough
and then there was a redneck dude and
then there was a dude with a hair lip
which was uh the three guys who ran the
fight and then there was a Richie Rich
with hair lip was it a cleft palate
cleft palate yeah isn't it I work with
Operation Smile which does um uh clef
palette like surgeries for babies like
all over the world through world
countries because a lot of them just
don't in America they just handle it
before you're even born yeah it's just
fascinating to me yeah he was uh it was
a good job I liked I love working with
animals there's I clean the Stalls every
morning and when I first went there
because the whole Barn was uh uh baby
goats sheep pigs uh cows was one of them
and I had to go in and clean them all
every morning everything I know about
leadership
um relationships as I learn more and
more in um grieving animals know what to
do you know so when you learn the herd
mentality and when you learn the way
that they I mean they all know how to
cope with grief like you know the Wolves
they prepare for the next Alpha years
before they start dying like herds no
animals have funerals like they just
know what to do humans are so confusing
to me and Serpentine and like the fair
and have motives like animal pre animals
they don't have motives like the herd
comes first right you know and they
don't value anything except Serenity and
calm oh you don't think you're fucking
smart who the fuck knows that
who knows that it's why I've always
animals are my Prime like they're my
primary Educators so I grew up just you
know with animals of you know so and I
do Equine Therapy with rescue animals
with kids that have autism and sexual
assault survivors and at risk youth and
stuff and there's because kids I don't
want to get boring here
um and I want to get back to the you but
um if it's interesting at all so a
couple things you know you can't tell a
kid you know you have a problem you have
anger problem the 13 year old kid you at
13 right so the last thing a 13 year old
10 year old wants to talk to is an adult
authority figure right right yeah that's
exactly 100 that's the they don't trust
authority figures so
there's a place called wolf connection
that when my dad died I actually just
drove straight there when my dad died
the grief you just go be near wolves
like don't just drive into the woods and
find wolves this is a sanctuary you know
that I um criticized sanctuaries a lot
because a lot of them a lot of them are
scams this one is not it's uh wolf dogs
and wolves so um in a lot of places a
lot of times it's Texas yeah I love you
Texas my mom is half from there but
y'all are a nightmare when it comes to
animals and exotic animal ownership for
your own benefit so we'll say um get
wolves they breed them with white German
Shepherds and they fight them so pitbull
fighting is big but wolf dog fighting is
also huge okay so they rescue wolves
wolf dogs some are um have more genetic
uh code of wolves but they're raised by
humans so they more behave like
domesticated dogs and then vice versa
you can have ones that have less
genetics but are wild so they behave
more like wolves so you know what's
funny about what you're saying and I
never put no truly nothing no not funny
but it's um
and I never put this together
when I worked on that farm right
I started there and I was I was I was
Furious I literally was passing out from
the shit smell and the piss cleaning a
sheep stall that's what handkerchiefs
are for I mean fucking I literally
almost died for the first week there it
was just terrible and there was no you
just go do it I mean just do it and I
had to take all the shit throw it away
shit it's terrible and
um by the end of the summer
you know I actually that was the end I
actually wound up drinking again but I
was working every day so much that I
would come and go to sleep I was tired
and I stopped drinking I stopped using
drugs if you're inhaling it but I
stopped hanging out with these kids and
I actually fell in love with this job
and I the last time I drank and used
drugs I remember I didn't want to I
didn't want to and I went and I fucking
I went with these kids had a half a
bottle of white label Scotch I did
whippets I did beers I did joints and it
nothing worked and I remember we we
robbed gumball machines but because I
was in prison already that I you just
immediately go to jail and I remember I
got arrested and I went back to jail
that night
but I remember I I I remember that this
this farm and being with those animals
changed me as a PR as a boy as this
little fucked up angry Boston you know I
had Joe Dash jeans and a wife beater and
mirror shades on a farm we still call it
a wife beater we did back then still do
and um I I remember that I I remember I
remember walking on the street my mom we
are always at odds and we actually held
hands one day and we opened up a bank
account with the little money that I was
making from this farm and she helped me
and we made this connection for the
first time in years now you know I was
in and out of jail and fast homes all
those from 13 or 12 to 15 but that farm
changed me and I never put that together
until you said that that animals being
with those animals I remember I'd have
lunch by myself and I I'd go on a little
baby goat stall and I would sit there
and they would come up and put their
head had on me and we would just push
each other's heads do that if they don't
want to and I and I loved it but I was
by myself but happy for the first time
in my life you know why
because I was gay
sodomy is very satisfying because
because I think you know why I don't
know why I don't know why
well two things I would observe and and
just throw out there I don't know
anything but my guess can I say why I do
know why okay because I I felt love
the love from animals isn't the kind of
love the human love has strings attached
it feels like pressure but also
well animals Animal love can become I
mean if you have a cat they're a little
cunty
cats can really stress really walking
into a hornet's nest here listen cats
you were about to get a whole female fan
base out of this listen I'll say what
just I mean just with one comment cats
I'll tell you why I love cats I had a
cat I rescue a cat off the Middle Street
and I rest and never gave me a nut like
would give me something then leave me
what's going on with you that you need
it adults can't be abandoned I mean it
just hurt she hurt my bonus hurt my
feelings once in a while I mean yeah
cats are I would have cats if I could I
just have many huge huge dogs and I
rescue so cats you really have to get
all your internal needs met internally
with cats you you they don't you can't
cats is like dating a young hot chick
it's like hey what do you want to go
tonight I don't care
hot chick that hates your cat yeah yeah
it destroys everything you love they
jump up and you think hey where were you
at work I'll be right back I gotta go
like wait wait no no no no yeah it's
like who gets mad at you when you cheat
on them but won't fuck you yeah so it's
like what am I in this for
yeah um your personality isn't good
enough to just be friends like you know
so
something I would observe which is um so
I'll go back to the wolf connection
thing in a second because when we do
Equine Therapy with sexual assault
survivors at-risk youth you know we
forget when you think sexual assault
survivors what do you think girls
um usually you go to yes 100 yeah but no
one will talk about the boys no them
included no we gotta take it so not only
do you have to take it we like think
it's funny in society well no one gives
a shit I'll tell you why because as a
kid from Boston and and growing up in
the 80s you're gay
and if you're gay
if someone was wrong that was like
before being gay was okay you know what
I mean it was being molested by someone
else when you're five means you're gay
yeah I mean the whole that whole thing
was like fuck so you bury everything you
just and then you it comes out and and
rage tried to write a joke about this
and maybe I just wasn't like I hadn't
earned the right to talk about it yet
because you know me too everyone comes
at me is that I'm like a you know is
whatever I'm not like just blindly
tweeting crazy shit before I do a little
research on the situation
um but um
you know I was trying to write a bit
about how like basically in Hollywood if
an actress gets hugged too long like the
whole business shuts down
but if a kid gets molested like by the
Catholic Church literally no one cares
there's no March there's no charity
there's nothing there's nothing the only
the best case scenario is you go to AAA
right with so many people I know in
aaathe less did and those meetings take
place in a church so you have to go back
to the fucking scene of the crime I
think though you know what's weird about
like I think about because I have my
nine-year-old now right and he's gonna
he you know look he has things you know
about sex yeah you know he you know
he'll his little fucking wiener will be
hard in the morning he doesn't know you
don't have Playboys lying around like
that's like what are they gonna do this
is the thing is that when I grew up
there was no sex was everywhere
and all of a sudden uh HBO came out sex
was on there like it was everywhere
house so like because magazine there was
magazines there was all of a sudden
cable was out and there was remember
Maxim and stuff I mean there was
everywhere and nobody but nobody talked
about it you I was raised Catholic Irish
Catholic Boston you didn't fight nobody
taught you about it nobody told you
about it you learned from whatever shit
you saw at older kids did you watch
movies like The English Patient like did
you repair like do you have like
Blockbusters yeah uh you know I mean all
this stuff was like Animal House
remember National Lampoon's European
Vacation that was the first time I saw
boobs I mean look uh was it last
American Virgin
so we that's what we're learning from
right it's like the auto body shop you
hope your dad takes you so you can see a
calendar 100 or you know my uncle's uh
under his bed he has Penthouse you know
so you go through there it was it was
funny
the same but now I think like I have a
kid he doesn't there's nothing he's not
he's going to learn about sex I think we
should when it's time Playboy is like
because it's time to learn about sex
well Gail dines
um this is a TED Talk uh worth listening
to you know I think it's a little bit
you know I'm not totally anti-porn I
think it's just more like the the
ability to access it so quickly there's
this great book I have it somewhere
called porn Nation that's worth reading
um you know uh and then in the special
not like this one the last one I did
with the sex robot sort of talking about
like how sex robots could be helpful in
a way I know it's a tricky territory but
now it's every 9 10 11 14 year old boys
right to go I want to see some titties
sure you know but if you go online now
you go to the Internet yeah World Wide
Web whatever the kids are calling it and
you go
to boobies
you're gonna what the first search is
gonna be anal fisting gang bang you're
gonna see something you didn't even ask
to see too fast whereas like it's normal
and healthy to see boobies and you know
so uh it's almost like you know this
reminds me of you know the comedian Dan
Mintz I love them he's so genius he has
one of my favorite jokes of all time he
goes you know when I was a kid he talks
really monotone and sort of you know and
I was okay Everything's changed in porn
now when I was a kid you know I used to
have to wait for the Sears catalog to
come and then I would you know flip to
the bra lingerie section and now with
modern technology I can just go to
sears.com
so I feel like we should just bring
magazines back for young boys so they
can see girls with pubes real boobs
because if you go straight I know guys
that have not seen
you know I'm dating someone who grew up
on porn and like doesn't think women
labia a lot of porn stars have
labioplasties which means they remove
their labia so their vagina hasn't
doesn't have that big um like rooster
uh chin rooster hangy thing the little
gobblego wizard yeah you know like
between vagina lips there's usually a
gizzard hanging but porn stars will
remove it so that it's more quote
unquote attractive and then they don't
have pubes no I don't have pubes either
but guys should know that they're there
yeah but I don't think like you know my
like I'm gonna have to teach my son
about this stuff and you know but I want
to take that like European approach
where like tits ain't a real big deal
like porn it's not a big deal like sex
it is to him right now though but he I
mean not right now because nobody he
asked me what an orgasm was the other
day he asked me about you know that's
your wife
I think I've made her coming along I
think throwing a chicken at my face is
the only way I can come because
um but like he asked he he's asking
about certain things but he's not
subjected to it he hasn't seen it yet at
nine he's not how do you know don't you
think his friends are showing him stuff
on phones older brothers friends older
brothers I'll tell you what I know that
I I think he would come to me and tell
me because there's certain things that
he has told me about you can use my sex
robot if you want you have a sex robot
no I'm gonna use that is it a guy
what is it what do you mean a sex robot
what are you talking about he's not as
big of a fan of me as I am of him yeah
but you have a fucking you have a dude
that with a penis no I got a sex robot
made for my um
Third special oh I remember this yes and
she talks and she's anatomically correct
yeah and here's the problem with this I
had a joke about sex robots too and my
thing was they're fantastic but they're
not good yet it's not good yet because
they haven't figured out what to do with
the jizz you still have to clean it like
a cup correct and I don't do regular
dishes never mind uh a fucking vagina
the fact that you've been would want to
clean it out is is I say the joke that
my my robot would look like Han Solo
Frozen and and in the fucking the wall
I've never seen Star Wars but I know
that's fine you don't have fucking Star
Wars fucking you're so attractive but
I'm saving it I'm I'm saving my Star
Wars virginity for my new guy that's the
only I have a couple virginities that
I've saved because for the one because I
some you can't save but I've never seen
Goonies I've never seen Star Wars I've
never seen Star Trek I've never uh
um there's a couple star what
star what wars did you see Star Trek
I said Star Trek Star Trek Star Trek I
thought you said star track track no I
don't know what it was I think you're
just trying to embarrass me I'm sorry I
did not mean you're bad I thought it was
actually adorable that you said it's on
track which is fucking great that you
have no idea okay Terry what is it
t-re-k
remember when you thought I was smart
let's go back to that you are smart and
you're fucking nut and the fact that
you've literally helping you've you're
this is what I like about you that
you're taking all the stuff you got
right and you're helping people which is
the to me I never wanted to be his Robin
Hood yeah I love that my thing with
Hollywood is I think what happened was
I'm still trying to put the pieces
together because my sister and I just
have been estranged and reconnected yeah
is I knew I had to make money somehow
and I knew I had a skill
but I knew the main skill was I know I
could outwork anyone yeah and I want to
get back to the farm thing because when
you come up on a farm you're just
working constantly constantly as soon as
you clean up the shit more shit's coming
out just keep going it's the uh animals
those animals shit like four or five
times a day so it's like it never ends
it's just whack you're just always
working and you enjoy it like I get so
much gratification of completing things
we get uh productivity and cooperation
make dopamine
and a lot of people don't think about
that because they go I don't want to
work I don't want to do something it's
like but that's actually going to be the
thing that makes you feel complete and
build what Pride so the first time it's
very interesting because it's a recovery
yeah you're in recovery I'm in recovery
Al-Anon 14 years in ACA Al-Anon okay
great but I identify as an alcoholic and
and all these words are meaningless
Don't Panic with I might alcoholic I'm
no no alcoholic it's a self-diagnosed
disease so don't panic if anyone calls
you one they just don't know anything
about it and they're scared and either
really love you or really want to hurt
you it doesn't matter the point is that
in order for alcohol
in order for alcoholism to be present
alcohol doesn't have to be present so
you don't only have to be addicted to
alcohol you can also be addicted to
perfectionism codependence other
people's perceived needs right for
managing the three acts smothering
modern micromanaging you know so a lot
of us were raised by moms that were
unrecovered alanons
chronic gifting chronic cooking chronic
caretaking you know and and then the
um the codependents breeds resentment
and that's but we're addicted to control
controlling other people and hooking
other people being so nice to them and
loving them so much that they'll never
leave us but it actually makes this um
um like sick tether right so actually
when you chase something you chase it
away and my favorite I kind of do well
with aphorisms uh if you hold sand in
your hand like this flat out you can
hold it forever but if you hold it like
this you're gonna lose it so the idea is
don't hold on too tight to anything
that's a good one you know that one so
trains can go side by side forever but
as soon as they Collide your fuck so we
move together like the herd and we don't
well one of the biggest things in the
program is helping others
being of service dog you have to your
help is really can be very confusing too
well okay I don't need to be shitty I
don't care about that it doesn't that
doesn't matter to me to help somebody
else or whatever word you need to use
because some people is is because help
is selfish sometimes so that's why we
say to actually I I agree with you on
that I I tripped up on that at first no
it's fine but I I think the one of the
biggest things you have to give it away
to keep it you know what I'm saying and
and giving it away is selfish because
that keeps me sober yeah 100 and and
it's a hard thing to do because once you
get it you want to just Coast on it and
I feel good finally I figured it out and
you want you stop doing those things
yeah I don't need it anymore I got what
I needed from you and how and and help
us giving service to other people it's
really hard to do
it's easy to get to but once you do it
it's hard to maintain that because
um you know there are ups and downs to
that it does become like fuck yeah you
know what I mean well it's also the
reason you don't want to do it the
reason I don't want to do it yep is
because alcoholics were the only people
that think we deserve to be having fun
all the time all the time and sometimes
it's not fun to have to sit down and
listen to someone who has less knowledge
than you even there even though you were
there five years ago and someone was
patient with you yeah but now I have to
it's so funny going to program when I
first went into Al-Anon I was like these
people are dumb
they're depressed I'm just coming here
to find out how to get the addicts in my
life sober I don't need any of this
sponsor okay I'm too busy for this ego
ego like I just I have the disease that
tells you you're perfect you know I got
all this you're so ahead of your time
you're an old soul you're so precocious
you're so organized you're so on top of
it that's the Insidious nature of the
Al-Anon disease the people that grew up
with alcoholic parents because we had to
become adults so young and fix
everything and you know so we're super
um uh we can solve anyone's problem in a
heartbeat we put everyone ahead of
ourselves we martyr ourselves in a way
that is actually self-deprivation and
not sustainable
etc etc but it took me so long to get
humble in that
I did it took me a year I used the
program to get sicker for the first year
because then I was like well I'm an
Al-Anon so any relationship I was in
well I'm an Al-Anon and they say that
I've never done anything wrong and I did
my blameless inventory and you're my
primary caretaker and it's a one-way
like I just used it because then I went
in and went oh I'm a victim whoa I had
it in my head I had even more power
because I actually was told I was a
victim and I had it hard and I hadn't
thought that before it didn't occur to
me your childhood's just your childhood
yeah and then I would share in meetings
and people like whoa you had it hard and
I'm like oh my God now I'm special
now I'm terminally unique like all that
shit so it I had to relapse again and
again on drug add people that were in
active Addiction on work on getting
really sick on you name it seven dollars
in my bank account for
seven years stealing from people to be
able to keep going to The Comedy Store
didn't steal from The Comedy Store but
stealing from like Neighbors in my you
know so I could live in this apartment
that was near the comedy store because I
knew I had to be able to walk to the
comedy store because I didn't have a car
it's time but who cares I'm being uh
just to get to your point what I did
feel lucky because I grew up half the
time on a farm
what completing tasks does for me
personally and you know with
productivity and cooperation making
dopamine it builds Pride
it's it's build prize and responsibility
to me to to wake up I had to wake up so
early and and drive my bike because I
didn't nobody would give me a ride in
the countryside
three and a half miles in the dark to
sunlight and now if you bring up those
peacocks I knew I was close because I
would hear that fucking Scream the
rooster or peacock peacock whatever the
fuck that was and it would scare the
shit out of me awesome and then but
it was a struggle to get out of bed in
the dark and to go up those Hills and if
some of them had a walk up the hill and
then you get there but all of a sudden
the responsibility and then the work
would give me this accomplishment and it
gave me Pride it gave me I was humble
around these animals I was grateful
um and I was around good people
like the people that worked on the farm
were good people
and because because there's no room for
ego on a farm it's not about whose job
is it it's whoever's closest it's if I
if I if and when you if I if you and I
are live together on a farm if I walk by
a pile of shit and don't clean it up I'm
going he's going to clean it up I just
someone's got to do it well that was the
one thing someone's getting shit on by
animals
once you get kind of used to that also
it's just shit it's just shit like
you're not there's a hose right there
the I think your immune system stronger
the first week they have a spreader you
know what a spreader is they put all the
shit in it yes and then they you know so
I don't know let's make it fertilizer
yeah all right so we're waiting um
animal shit is Magic like it's magic
It's Magic right so they have to take
this I have to throw all the stuff in
the spreader and then the guy would take
the tractor and the spreader up this
hill but I'm like fuck I had a weed of
con so after I cleaned the Stalls I have
to go weed a cornfield by hand
so I'm in this cornfield I'm fucking
it's torture was still not as hard as
what any slave did right but it's for an
hour it's close yeah I mean it was close
I mean I'm enjoyed our scenes those are
tight right and uh
so I say to this guy one day I go yo let
me come with you let me help you and it
was your old redneck and he's like I
gotta go spread this I go uh I'm cool
just I'll do whatever you need me to do
it goes okay you have to make sure the
stuff comes out so he brings me up this
hill I'm on a tractor we get up to this
big field he pulls the thing up he goes
all right I need you to get behind
this the spreader and when it starts
coming out just whistle and let me know
it's coming out
so I'm behind it now mind you there's
seven different animal shits and pisses
it's full it's attractive this trailer
of shit so I'm behind it and it goes you
ready and I was like yep
hit the button
and these things shoot shit out at 9 000
miles
it just went
that's my stand-up 10 years ago shit and
literally the front of my body was
covered with shit
just the whole front was covered you
heard him going ha and I just walked
back down the hill in the heat which is
shit and went back to the cornfield and
just started picking weeds again
probably why your skin is so good God
damn that's magic uh yeah but that that
type of that type of work and that type
of humility and that I think had a big
uh big thing in change in my life
responsibility because then you can
build so in order people like the basis
for all of our insecurities right
whatever word you want to use in order
to build self-esteem you have to do
esteemable actions so that's something
that it took me a while to click because
there's all you can go online you can
see quotes love yourself reading a quote
from brene Brown she's lovely she's very
smart reading following a bunch of feeds
on Instagram about how to build get
self-esteem and double tapping it
doesn't build self-esteem everyone's
running around with this artificial
confidence right now that really just
feels like
um like uh misguided ego and it's and I
think people are getting embarrassed by
it because like yeah I'm a this I'm a I
didn't want to make me I'm not trying to
make fun of girl boss but I think
there's just like girl power it's just
these like meaningless words but it took
me a long time to realize that why do I
have such low self-esteem I I have
confidence there's a difference between
confidence and self-esteem I have a lot
of confidence in what I'm good at when I
go on stage I'm very confident that
doesn't mean I have high self-esteem or
I don't think I deserve to be there
necessarily so in order to build
self-esteem you have to engage in
esteemable actions which means you're
being of service with no strings
attached it can no one it's not for
people to see so if you're doing it just
for people to see that you're doing
something nice doesn't count so if it's
as simple it started with me after I've
been in program for a couple years and I
went okay I need to think about someone
at Neil Brennan once said to me made me
laugh
um so hard this is maybe like 12 years
ago he was sitting with Dove David off
twice I bring up Dev in this had the
Coffee Bean on Sunset and they would
meet there every morning and one morning
I like was leaving like just to go
somewhere and I didn't say bye and I
turned around I was like all right bye
because I was gonna see them that night
yeah saying hi and bye I never know if
that's necessary but it's another story
Small Talk hugs I just feel like we
don't need them but
that's a whole other thing and so I
turned you know the hugger I I'm not not
a hugger but I think and I don't mean to
bring gender into it but
I wanted to give everyone permission at
The Comedy Store it's like if I hug one
person I have to hug everyone and I feel
like because I'm a girl everyone thinks
they have to hug me yeah and I'm like I
saw you last I see you every night like
it's just like you know and then if I
don't hug someone else it feels like I
don't like the dance of are we gonna hug
are we not I like just go let's not
we'll hug when when my when someone dies
when something great happens they're
hugging every single night is just like
you're a good hugger I'm a great hugger
if I don't have to do it all the time
give me a hug it was a great hug and I
needed it yeah it was a great hug good
hug thank you that was like uh that
meant a lot to me but these I don't like
obligatory hugs yeah no I agree with you
ever since I got fake tits everyone
wants to hug me so I have your fake tits
yeah oh what kidding I know
so I just don't want to lose this train
of thought because it really helped me
yeah so I had this neighbor where I
lived uh like eight years ago and he had
this long driveway and I would watch him
pull push his
what's the word garbage can sorry I know
did you watch me just leave I was going
to help what do you think happened I
don't know I think I went I was gonna
say slay I didn't know I thought we're
gonna do it yeah
um and so I'd watch him carried out
because I would go running by and then I
was like oh I'm gonna go ask if I can
just every Thursday
take his trash out for him
I do know yeah I might be robbing him of
his own Pride right so when we help
people quote unquote that's why the word
help I get stuck on it because it's like
you're implying it's it's like we try to
balance giving people the Dignity of
their own experience and going if you
take away someone providing or doing
hard work you're taking away their
ability to feel the pride of having
finished the work right so right the big
thing when people like kids on their
phones all the time my opinion that it's
it's it's only as harmful as we make it
except that people do well when they do
hard things when they when they um build
proof that they're valuable and that's
how they get Pride so I asked him I was
like hey can I you know on Thursdays
come by and take your trash out yeah or
bring your basket bins down I don't know
why I'm bumping on this work and um he
said yes dude because you don't take
your own trash out and that's that's why
yeah
you give somebody else you let them be
otherwise I'm robbing someone of a job
you let somebody else help you of
service no I pay them that's that's
service oh hi taking a break from Robert
Kelly to talk about why I look so good
all the time it's shock it is I'm I'm
truly shocked and I'm gonna I'm gonna go
with circuitous route here before I talk
about this osia these products I've
talked about them before I have been
using this product
truly for I want to say like six years
Jessica Beale
talked about this being her favorite oil
in a magazine I think it was a lore
magazine there was a thing in the back
that was like like celebrity like pics
and I bought it based on that because I
don't think that that bitch doesn't lie
like I just I know this about her most
actresses probably do they lie for a
living and get awards for how good they
aren't pretending she's like so real I
don't know I met her a couple times and
I'm just like I trust you and why do you
look like a newborn babe all the time so
got this I've been using this on my face
my entire body
I want to give away my secrets Pat what
if everyone starts looking as good as me
it's gonna mess up the bell curve I have
this no joke next to my toilet in my
bedroom
and I reapply it to my face when I'm
peeing in the middle of the night
gave up my I gave this that's the secret
that's it right here when I tell you
this smell the smell
it's like um it smells like clean if the
ocean wasn't polluted is what it smells
like it just it's a look I'm so obsessed
with it it's the purest look at the back
look at the cruelty free vegan uh gluten
free and then please recycle
it's a game changer get this for
everyone in your life their best seller
mini collection okay that's the perfect
perfect gift only available for a
limited time six piece set of luxurious
skin care and Body Care favorites
inconvenient and adorable little travel
size for a complete glow up from head to
toe it's packaged in a beautiful box
that's easy to gift wrap but with
packaging this pretty you can skip the
wrapping all together clinically proven
results for an unmatched body care
experience look how luminous I look I
look like a I look like a marzipan
ballerina all of OCS products are clean
clinically proven and consumer tested
their perfect addition the perfect
Edition you know what I meant to your
winter skincare and body care routine
for a gift that will impress check out
OCS bestseller mini collection right now
our listeners get 10 off your first
order with promo code good for you at
osea malibu.com you'll even get free
samples with every order and orders over
fifty dollars get free shipping that's
10 off at OC o-s-e-a malibu.com promo
code good for you
I've been with Leslie my quote unquote
cleaning lady but she's my sister mother
um for 16 years so I clean before she
comes over so the whole thing my wife
does the same thing because your wife's
a lady we love our cleaning lady which
is the best yes it's you're not a
cleaning lady you're a in the tribe of
women your family yeah you know and so I
actually pee on the seat when she's
coming
I'm kidding I don't do that I feel like
you pee on the seat all the time listen
oh God I try not to I try not to my son
is fucking I mean outrageous super
soccer because he just started getting
hard-ons oh I can't say this oh I love
oh yeah I I don't whatever I just want
you to be clear I want to be be on me
for that and see when he said his son
had hard on to how horrified I was not
aroused there isn't I'm dating a younger
man and so I just want to make sure well
I never because as as a parent like
these things are as a dad I'm like okay
I I know this was going to come up and
then when it does come up it's like Dad
why does this stick out straight and I'm
just you know I'm giving I gave him I
was like well because blood goes to it
in the morning
um and true feminist you'll hire him a
sex worker to take care of that when
he's of age of age no he's not gonna
need that he'll take care of himself
he'll meet a girl who needs it taken
care of two or a boy it might be a boy
who knows all right I just don't want
him up there in the woods getting Lyme
disease yeah I might have a nice little
pedophile
my kid's hot with another boy no can you
be a pet oh yes okay if you're nine can
you be if you're if you're nine and you
like no molest a five-year-old are you a
pedophile that's just having fun
I should be in France's life story it's
just that's just sex you know just
floating around but so the taking the
trash out yeah and not telling anyone
about it we took a fucking right I've
never that's this alt right that's so
sorry welcome to a female podcast you're
fucking you you do work on another level
I I I'm digging it like you're a fucking
brain
it's almost calming to me like the way
your brain works it's calming like it's
like hypnotic it's like relaxing
I did work for your coffee
did you I mean no I'm serious like
you're you're fucking you really
your thoughts are fast and and uh
um clear something did click for me and
everyone in the audience is going to
know this interview is different as much
as I want to take that compliment and
act like I've always been like this on
this podcast something clicked for me in
your podcast
um after listening to it and then with
my mom dying
um so passing Crossing away again you
know 12 years it's been 12 years please
no one pity me it was so before I lived
in this secondhand embarrassment all the
time because when people bring up their
parents
um
you know I'd always sort of pretend she
was fine and she was just staring at a
wall and it was just torture to always
just be imagining her in the back of my
mind
and I was always in this Rush of like
is today going to be the day that she's
gonna die so my phone I was always like
thinking I was never like I couldn't be
present before
and something I heard on the podcast
yesterday and I don't mean to be
confrontational I really hope this
doesn't come off that way but I just
wanted to uh uh tether this um close the
hatch on that again
um helping this guy not helping being of
service with the bins really helped me
start building self-esteem just very
basic being of service for other people
with no strings attached not to brag and
tell other people just really to do it
to be of service to someone else who
actually needed it being of service to
people that don't actually need it can
be selfish and you're trying to sort of
like
um prove to them you're a good person
and then you're just bringing them into
your manipulation that's a little
different but so in the podcast you
mentioned you were talking about you I
came up on your podcast while I was
listening to it as a fan which is a very
surreal moment right and I just wanted
to address
um in a way that so we can build our
friendship if you're interested
addressing you know and part of the
reason when I did the only fans roast I
really wanted to Rose myself is to be
able to address
the Optics of me during the pandemic
yeah because I think everyone thought I
kind of like lost my mind yeah
and you know it's interesting because I
I agree that you know it's the first
time I've ever done Edibles I had never
done Edibles before I would do them
during the day you know it was the
pandemic like Tim Dillon was over we
thought we were done
we thought we were Tim Dylan didn't do
edibles but I had to do them to be able
to tolerate them abuse
um but I mean there was a time there
where I mean truly after like three or
four months in it was like are we really
ever
I mean imagine someone
performance in the pandemic going back
to where you were mentally imagine just
a customer going to The Cellar
in the dark taking a glass with a straw
from a string like it just it was
unfathomable when we were wiping down
groceries yeah that Ed that comedy
wouldn't be the first to go a business
that's predicated on a bunch of
strangers shoulder to shoulder yeah
exhaling droplets on each other for two
hours it just was like this is never
coming back that's how it felt for a
little while you know so I was like okay
this is my opportunity to do what
everyone else is doing all this micro
dosing all this I micro dosed
um uh a nasal spray right
um but that wasn't really on camera as
much but then
this is this is the real thing that I
think it's worth discussing because I
dyed my hair a bunch of different colors
yep which I've talked Ad nauseam about
about sort of why
number one all my friends that were hair
and makeup artists they were losing
their health insurance they were moving
home they were I mean you know the only
thing more disposable than comedy at
that time you know they couldn't do Zoom
pair appointments of dying you know so I
had a bunch of friends that were herods
and I just was like what's the most
expensive thing you can do you know and
dying it bleaching it and then dying it
blue or whatever so then I dyed my hair
yeah
um because my sort of and I know I'm
being facetious a little bit but the pan
my behavior during the pandemic I feel
like was the first time I wasn't acting
insane because before that
before the pandemic I was always keeping
my hair brown and perfect so that
Hollywood casting directors would cast
me and I was like trying to not you know
um I was trying to be perfect so that
the head of fox would want to fuck me
and so that I could be the girl next
door but also you know No One's Gonna
hire the girl with the blue hair that
looks insane yeah so for me it was like
that was a time where I felt like for
the first time I actually Oh I thought
you were losing your fucking brain and I
might I might have I thought you because
I wasn't I wasn't it's it's like I was
like what's up wit what's going on and
I'll say what the main thing is because
I think this is just funny yeah and it's
weird that I happen to you is that the
thing is with having blue hair
if it's if it's first of all it's two
thousand dollars just to get it done for
what to get it totally bleached and
totally I mean that's crazy but well I
guess saying what you listen here's the
thing about life but then the roots when
they're as soon as the roots go out
people think here's what sucks about
life right my perspective is only my
perspective and what I have right so
then you add the I'm trying to help
these other people have a job and I'll
let you die my fucking head
if I had that situation and my friends
were hair dressers I'd let you dry dye
my asshole hair and I charged me three
thousand dollars so you can have money
too but you know what I'm saying that to
me is just give them the money but if
you believe it that's no that's not I
love that's epic to me I think people
that you you are fuck service I'm saying
is that you like I don't know that
perspective of you I just hey I know you
what's up hey Whitney what's going on
yeah yeah blah blah and then I see you
and all of a sudden you have a llama and
your hair is purple and blue I'm like
what's up but it's a it's fascinating to
me you're you're correct but from my
perspective because I agreed I was like
I must be going crazy you know that's
how it felt you know Matt the great
Madison Sinclair brilliant writer oh
you're not smart wrote on the road who
the fuck brings that up she's a comedy
writer yeah I know but like how do you
just whip shit like I don't remember
anybody's name I met people yesterday I
don't fucker that little twinkie dude
that works here I don't even know his
name what's his name how about this if
someone's funnier than me I remember
okay fair enough my my future enemies
that are fighting at my heels Madison
Sinclair Numero Uno all right people
overthrow me
um if I have any kind of rain that
sounds like somebody that like uh helps
slaves I just started watching Game of
Thrones I just watched the pilot Madison
Sinclair is a like uh she Madison
Sinclair helped the slaves back in the
day she's just brilliant she's a female
zakamiko really an LA comic yep okay
great brilliant and she um oh she said
to me I was like why is everyone so
weird about because we did the roast of
me I recommend ever doing everyone
having a roasted themselves it is so
educational you learn so much about the
way you're perceived because you know I
think for I feel like I've been in this
dissonance and most of it is my fault
because I've worked so hard to pretend I
was someone I wasn't or impress other
people there's such a dissonance between
who I am and who I haven't perceived
like when I first went on Legion of
skanks everyone was like I can't believe
you're doing this the reason why it gave
me it actually a comic first I was very
it made me so happy to see you up there
because I did you do have a perspective
people and just to do that and the fact
that you oh I was talking I was talking
to and they were like I'm going to see
Whitney and I was like oh cool I think I
said hi to you on the phone or whatever
somebody was going to say hi to you no I
came up to you and asked you if for your
phone number because I wanted to have
you on the podcast no but you were
talking to somebody on the phone before
that who who somebody was over there
somebody was talking to you and they
were any Lettermen maybe nope are you
Garbage Guys I don't know who was it was
somebody maybe it was Norton or
something oh yeah maybe Norton but
because he was on the road right so but
the F when I came in there and I saw you
up there
just having fun being funny it gave me a
different like a perspective on you that
I had when I first met you that I kind
of maybe lost over the years because you
were off becoming successful right doing
or what you had to do and then and then
now I see you just hanging out I was
like oh she's fucking cool as shit
I was like gosh that's so fun man just
to see you up there of fucking hanging
out and what I did when my last special
came out that's why I love the skanks
though the skank Fest that Festival the
real it's the realest it's just because
you think it's this thing of fucked up
people it's the fan the best fans on the
planet or our Legion of skanks Fans Say
are true comedy fans I was scared I
think that I we're all scared I grew up
with open Anthony fans who are awesome
they're fucking amazing but there's a
small group of them that will fucking
step on your kid's head and videotape it
and make a meme and then call your
mother a cunt and they'll all laugh it's
just a you know the skin everyone knows
famously the open Anthony fans were the
ones that were responsible for the great
billboard Philadelphia
look at most of them I'm telling you you
weren't on that on right before oh
that's right not I mean they're fucking
amazing fans seriously but there's a
it's just a different generational thing
and now and finally specifically
fuck around man and but that the skank
Fest is such a great festival and the
fans are so awesome a lot of the fans
have
colored hair blue hair pink hair blue
hair I know it's just when you look out
and they're mentally ill but listen but
in a good way that's my other thing no
I'm kidding is that and I don't I'm not
a big like don't say this word say this
word but sometimes there's two times
you've already corrected me twice on the
show so it's kind of one time off yeah
transsexual I was right you are right
you are right I was right you were wrong
it uh more frequently than than you even
know because I was talking about an
adult I just have made the mistake
before saying when we say transsexual or
gay if they're not post-pubescent yeah
or sexualizing kids yeah so I I know
when you said because I don't have kids
so I'm limited and I was arrogant in
that moment
I was just wrong but I was also arrogant
because and I think sometimes when we
try to quote unquote pretend you just
watch me do the exact thing I'm in
recovery for which I tried to quote help
you by going don't say transsexual about
your kids I'm I'm perfectly because I
need help I'm I for the for for the
longest time I'm a huge uh a transsexual
transgendered uh supporter I I mean I
some of my my closest friends are that
and you know it sucks to me that comedy
and that whole world collided because
that whole world was together for so
long and then you know it collided uh
and and it sucks in a good way it's so
my next special is just about that oh no
shit recording it probably beginning of
I would like to do it with at only fans
with this with the um I love that only
fans is doing other stuff only fans is
can I tell you so so I think that and
please stop me if I'm being boring
because I really want to talk about you
I'm pretty I'm pretty sure they'll stop
if we're being boring they'll just hit
they might not most podcasts are really
boring but it's like I mean my favorite
podcast is just my actually isn't even
when Bill Burr's like really talking
it's when he's trying to figure out how
to plug in his computer yeah he's
fucking it must be boring and some but
it's not boring to me I'm like on the
edge of my seat is he gonna plug it in
is Nia is Nia gonna come back like I'm
so invested so I'm learning with
podcasts it's like if I'm if I need to
talk like this to make you interested
then you're on Adderall or something
like I can if you fuck with me you fuck
with me if you don't you don't I'm not
gonna like
like um being inauthentic to try to
accommodate some vague I've been on so
many podcasts recently because I've only
done my podcast for years and I had
people come to me because I've been
doing it for so long but you know when
the special came out one of the things
was is like I want to go start doing
podcasts and and the pandemic for you
was to go be free and try all these
things the pandemic for me and I had
just started a podcast so people were
seeing me pandemic personality for the
first time right the pandemic for me was
to get back to uh to fix myself because
I was a dry drunk for a long time so I
went back and tried to fix myself and
get my shit together and become humble
and grateful and do all you know service
and all this stuff we could clarify what
dry drunk means to you uh dry drug to me
is not drinking not using drugs and uh
but
um doing all the behavior that I did
when I was drinking and using drugs
being jealous Justified anger justify
resentment uh uh guilt uh um
um hatred
um depression you know sadness pity pot
um all this stuff that I did when I
drank
um I did the same thing and then I but I
had underlying causes which was food I
went into a massive food addiction which
is the worst because nobody cares and
because you have to eat three times a
day it's your alcohol you don't have to
drink three times not at all and nobody
cares you can't truly be abstemious an
alcohol or headache they'll put you in a
thing and they'll give you an
intervention when you're a food addict
they talk behind your back
they talk behind you back Bobby's fat as
fuck and then they forget because they
notice you you're this fat right the
only time you know you're fat is when
you see somebody who hasn't seen you in
a year and they're like what the fuck
happened to you they say nothing and you
know they know right so it that was
terrible for me because I'm here I am
and I'm surreptitious like would you
don't even fucking use that word in my
life but would you do it um eat
privately when I had so I talk about
I've talked about it publicly a lot I
struggle with eating disorders for years
years right uh say anorexia et cetera
and my you would never really I would
eat secretly in the car no no no
privately no it sucked for me because I
would eat out in the open because I
became the fat fuck I just owned it and
now all the comments and all the fear of
fat fuck I would just own it so what's
up with the noise maybe we won't hear it
you won't hear it I'm sorry about that
but I would sorry about that
um can I need a gum because my mouth was
fucking dumb normally on um I'm just
gonna I'm not the first okay I'm not
gonna chew it I'm gonna suck some juice
out of it I'm gonna get a little juice
out of there Jolly Rancher that would be
worse because one time an actor named
Topher Grace came on and he hadn't eaten
all day because they had just had a kid
got him a chicken sandwich he took one
bite I lost like a hundred thousand
subscribers all right no I just my mom's
getting dry I have something called
misophonia which is where I hear things
it's a hyper vigilance what the fuck
women have can hear we're we're
basically hardwired to hear longer
distances so anything that sucks about a
man and is annoying about a woman we
evolve to have these superpowers that
now because we live in the modern times
where we don't need them as much they
are become annoying who the fuck knows
that absolutely how do you not who knows
that I made a movie called the female
brand I'm obsessed with the biological
basis for listen you're highly
intelligent go don't ever think you're
not you have a lot you're very you're
very very smart the fact that you
whatever the fuck that was was crazy to
me well so it's like you know it's your
wife is like did you hear that you're
like hear what because she's designed to
my wife doesn't hear anything I say yes
I live like Dawn and then she she she's
so you're saying she chooses
she hears you that doesn't mean she's
listening okay I I will accept that
she's she you know what I mean so it's
we have very
um hyper Vigilant uh hearing the ability
to hear sounds further away Etc so so if
you have female fans they're gonna have
it's more when you're jogging or running
and you have headphones and and that
noise can be very stressful to people
with misophonia which is just like my
wife had listen my wife has misophonia
but she can't hear you no yeah because
she because okay TV's too loud radio's
too loud this is too loud when I Chomp
when I chew she'll fucking stab me with
a fork under the table she has that and
I this I'm learning so much from you
um so yeah but and now and she's not
exaggerating well now she's
pre-menopause add rage and hate and
she's about to have more testosterone
it's not Rage or hate it's she's gonna
she's gonna that's the if I had to if
someone took a picture of her face or
drew it when she looks at me and she
what is that feeling I'd be like that's
Rage or hate so you know that women
evolve to cry because uh men back then
it's changing and we're evolving certain
men because you can't read you haven't
evolved to read micro Expressions so
tears are basically to inform her Botox
doesn't happen either so I mean but it
helps with other things okay
that's the main thing like which I want
to talk about that I have to actually I
have a shirt that I I just admire you
that she gets Botox no I love that she
knew what she wants do you think that
I've had a lot of work done
um
you've had some
um my wife my wife is an esthetician in
New York for 20 years one of the head
estheticians in Manhattan at the top let
me tell you what I've done
um can I I'll guess okay ready because
you've seen me before whatever I have
done I know you you have you have
perfect lips but I think those are just
your lips right if I can do this that
means are real
see you can't do that I mean it's
frightening especially because my mom is
dying we took the picture but there's a
picture of me as a baby yeah and I look
like I look like a real housewife she
had some Botox in your forehead botox
anymore see those lines you see those
lines yeah yeah so I get I've gotten it
before right but I'll do it like I
initially got him for really bad
migraines yeah but also to look younger
because I was on a TV show where they
had to shut it down because they said I
look tired because it was definitely bad
eye bags okay I mean I now know how to
eye bags are genetic just to hold water
so if I'm shooting something where I
can't have eye bags like a movie or
something I just won't eat salt for like
a week right so both talks here see ding
ding ding dink yeah and then my nose is
really crooked normally yeah see my
nostrils how quickly they are yeah yeah
but my wife just got um but I get a tiny
bit of filler on this side of my nose
and that's my wife got micro needling uh
it's good for you she's got that done
one of her friends just make sure to do
it yeah good person Dr Bill who uh takes
care of her she used to work for him so
you know it's going to be expensive it's
in the name
no no he's not he actually gives her
deals because he used to work for and
he's a good friend of mine and he comes
to all my shows for nothing I just like
can I tell you the only reason I get
defensive about when people accuse me of
plastic surgery because I know it's a
big thing but she looks like you know
what she looked like when she got home
was it's frightening yeah she looked
like Deadpool yeah
for like three days biggest movie on the
planet he's hot well tell me what what
were you why were you only and this is a
recent thing because we did my roast and
every joke was Whitney plastic surgery
and
God Nick Swardson has the best joke
about my face I love Nick Swanson
funniest dude he funny I like just is
can't stop being fun like can't say
anything I can't even look at him
without laughing it's like I don't even
think I can be a good friend to him
right yeah because if he was going
through a hard time I don't know if I'd
even be able to fucking stop laughing at
him
um he used to blow my dog when we walked
down the street pretend to blow him it
was the most frightening thing he had a
little tiny uh silky terrier and he used
to pick Kelby up and go oh my God I love
and I'd be like stop
it he was like I'm kidding it's just
like made of because every fucking
mitochondria in his body is just fucking
made to be funny made me funny so made
in a lab
um so we did this thing together and I
do a laser called alfera Rick Glassman
just asked me about it
um it most lasers are scams topical
lasers they actually and I made this
mistake they thin your skin so a lot of
people do these topical lasers and also
when you do a lot of lasers it kills the
hair follicles on your face so a lot of
times these Real Housewife you know
remember Bill Burr's bit about how they
all look like lizards yeah old young
lizards or whatever it's because your
face starts looking shiny because
there's no hair because you do the laser
so that looks makes you look like you've
had more work done than you have when
you do lasers and it thins your skin
which means you're more susceptible to
sun damage which makes is going to make
you age faster so lasers can be a a lot
a lot of these con artist dermatologists
want to make a quick Buck Etc daily
maintenance is better
I don't even do facials but sorry
ulthera I go get this laser it does make
you pretty swollen so I did it it hurts
like all fuck what it does is it Heats
your
um epidermis so much yeah that it it um
so you know when you burn so I was in a
fire as a kid I have a burn on the side
of my leg do you have any burn scars no
okay so burn scar obviously it's going
to be kind of Chaffey I got one from
Chicken on my wrist the game Chicken no
I used to have I remember the uh Swanson
chicken meals you had to cook in the
oven loves chicken he's throwing it at
your wife you're throwing it out the
window it was an accident with the wife
don't say that because someone can take
that it was an accident I apologize and
she almost beat the shit out of me
um that was just Swanson J remember the
TV dinners the chicken heard it coming
and she was such a good hearing she
probably wanted it she could have ducked
it was like I just wanna fucking have
this
so yes anyway what it does is the reason
that this uh laser actually works it
hurts like all hell yeah they normally
will give you like a Vicodin or
something painkillers don't work on me
it's like West Virginia I'm made of like
aluminum or something but
it uh basically is so hot that you
produce collagen as a way collagen is
built to do as Scar Tissue okay and it
tightens right okay so naturally
tightens underneath your skin you do it
once a year it's it's expensive okay
I've done my arms I've done my stomach
I've done my butt like you know we'll
see
um
so
he's uh Nick Swardson is over yeah my
face is a little swollen like it looks a
little crazy and that's the thing about
like being a woman like before podcast
you could like take a week off for your
laser to heal now I'm just like on
camera for three hours and I'm like do I
go on camera I have this guy booked like
even though I look crazy I'm just that's
the other thing about why during the
pandemic when my hair roots weren't done
and my hair wasn't brushed I was just
like I feel you don't have hair you get
to just go on I look like I look like
what he loved because like I don't have
three hours to do my hair every day you
know so it was like
blue dyed hair is hot when it's an anime
girl or a Comic-Con but if it's not
brushed you look like you're on drugs
and mentally like you know so I just was
like now look I have a brush right here
now I brush my hair I know I have to
brush my hair you guys are going to
think I'm mentally ill in a bad way I
think I'm I like my mental illnesses
they help me they're my friends they
um they don't help you they service you
they they do yes nightly so anyway this
is the biggest build up this is a
fucking building I'm an editor I'm gonna
that's how confident I really are edging
this shit this is the most confident I
am in the joke because it's Nick
swardson's it's not mine this is a
fucking setup
um so he's sitting across from me
telling me a story about him and Mark
Maron yeah about how he went on Marin
and he thought he was really good
friends with Mark and Mark was like yeah
I've always hated you man and he's like
what I thought we were friends like it's
the funniest story ever and this was
back when I think I was a little more
insecure and I would like I was I
interrupt and I think I'm helping the
Audience by like like going and then he
did that like I think I'm helping the
guest by like telling some of their
story or something it's so annoying I
hate when people do it and I do it you
be but you're listen can I say something
you're a talker you like talking and you
have a lot to say like like I said you
work on another level like it's almost
calming to me you know that we're having
this conversation right now but I feel
guilty not as much anymore people will
say no if they don't want to but having
people because I thought David Spade
said one time you know podcast how do
you remember all this doing someone
else's podcast is like jury duty so I
always felt guilt having Comics come on
podcasts but I now have I'm gonna say it
I'm not being a narcissist I have an
incredible fan base I have a big fan
base yeah I love this podcast so I now
know I'm not they're not doing me a
favor I hate when people do me favors
and I never like to ask for favors so
part of the reason it's taking me so
long with you and Neil Brennan get ready
I never want someone to do me like I've
not felt like I've
I hear you I hear you listen I haven't
had Louie on my podcast because I always
felt I feel the same way it's not that I
don't feel good enough but it's like you
know you don't be like why haven't you
ask me well yeah like I asked him I
actually did ask him and he was like
yeah sure after the blah blah let's do
it but I understand what you're saying
but the one thing that I've learned from
doing this special and promoting it is
how
awesome
comedians are well now that we're that
way but we're at help let me finish at
at helping each other that where you
think that we're all in this and we're
teams and pockets and blah and what I re
and and that's not even as I came out of
this funk or whatever it is and now I'm
doing the special and I'm I'm going out
to these things how insanely generous
comedians are with their fan base which
some not all some covet they coveted it
because
what is your fans watching us right now
watching me who's this fucking ball they
might be good for you yeah so the way
the algorithm worked they could have
just watched you on are you garbage or
whatever and then seen you on mine not
know who I am and they go that's why I
always say but they have like it blows
me away how far amazing we are we're
here for you but um I just it blows me
away like so I saw this before I talked
to Giannis about you right and I was
like it's okay I don't I'm just cutting
off a little bit please do but I'm
saying Comedy Central all these networks
pitted us against each other we had to
compete now we didn't but we thought we
did but now we also did in a way it was
me versus like premium blend they picked
10. live at Gotham they picked 140 I was
not picked the year that I did the roast
I've never been picked never been picked
so it was me versus you so now yeah we
can all share right because we're not so
that's all I wonder the fact that like
Rogan
right the fact that the people he's
helped but he's it's on to him it's it's
selfish it's selfish to him it's yeah
and it's like you know like like Tom and
Christina and Christina
um I mean I the list goes on you know
some people are still in it a little bit
these are mine but the fans you can't
keep something that was never yours
they're not your fans they're my fans I
love that we took you're right we took
this power back and now we're just like
hey we'll take care of each other comedy
in America is in general stand-up comedy
is not even 100 years old like we're
also just like and it was it was just
ours for a long time it was just ours I
mean it really was an American and then
capitalism Hollywood and then yeah yeah
and then well yeah no but yeah convinced
us we were too dumb well technology too
made it worldwide you know we you know
they didn't have comedy in India no
Gatekeepers they didn't have it in
Europe that much they didn't have it in
Russia and China and it's changing yeah
it's changed it a lot you know and also
we're the first generation foreign that
not me for you like I um am doing this
uh Rodney Dangerfield's widow
um I'm reading this thing that she she
uh wrote based on her experience when he
was in a coma with all the comedians
coming by she documented all of it yeah
like I have summer Rodney's um pages
from The Tonight Show have you seen this
no no no no
sorry I'm now my ADD is taking over I
love I love your 80d
so the checks met it got an Applause
break oh that's great a a this was his
64th appearance on The Tonight Show wow
a a a check a check menopause break
sorry I think check met laugh
she explained the whole thing to me but
look at look at the first line great
crowd great crowd wow that's awesome
Isn't that cool that's amazing and she
explained like what everything meant
um wow so um I don't know where I'm
going oh we're the first generation
where we there's Legends like you that
are old enough or have been doing it
long enough to even be able to comment
on Legends you know so anyone that was
saying Lenny Bruce was a genius 30 years
ago yes obviously it was true but like
they were Comics but I think podcasting
did an amazing thing that nobody's kind
which I'm kind of realizing is that when
you're a stand-up you're by yourself
we're Headliners We're Alone we're by
ourselves on the road and we're not with
each other except maybe in The Comedy
Store The Comedy seller and that's just
a fucking hey but podcasting opened up
the thing where we can all be on me and
you and it's a Home Advantage You're
Gonna Come Into My Den I'm coming over
and you you're going to have me on and
we're just going to talk and we're going
to hang out and there's nothing to it
there's nothing but what's more intimate
than having someone in your home that
you worry might not like you yeah but it
but it but as soon as you start talking
to all these Comics I've been on it's
like dude it's instant family we we yeah
like it's not the club it's not the
headlining spot it's it's we're hanging
out talking
so podcasting made our community I think
for me I agree I I mean I'm I'm in awe
of all the people you Giannis Rogan Tom
Christina uh I mean the garbage guys I
mean all of them Santino look at I just
talked to Bobby Lee last night on the
phone with since he's like I thought you
hated me I'm like no no Bobby you hate
you I didn't hate you Bobby Lee everyone
loves you you hate you we've been
through this but it's funny you know
what I mean like like that podcast kind
of these things clear each other up for
some reason but people that are your
enemies will take things out of context
and intentionally people are now I want
enemies what I want to say about the dry
drunk thing I have no enemies is that a
lot of people and I have compassion for
them are sick and suffering with the
internal
drug cabinet so the dry drunk thing of
if someone was thinking while you were
talking who's not yet to a place of
clarity like you is like wait a second
how can you do all the things
off of alcohol and drugs that you did on
alcohol and drugs that doesn't make any
sense that sounds maybe like an
exaggeration if that was going through
your mind you know there's something
called the internal drug cabinet
adrenaline cortisol adrenaline makes
dopamine so if you aren't drinking or
doing drugs you can get up we have DMT
naturally producing in our brain we can
make those drugs so if you create drama
for yourself
anyone who says I hate drama
chances are you're creating drama for
yourself on a regular basis to get the
adrenaline speeding when you're so let's
say you know this is like Al-Anon 101 so
if I first start working with the spawn
C first question I usually have is if it
takes 30 minutes to get somewhere and
you have to be there at four o'clock
what time do you leave
I would leave at three o'clock great
that would be the positive contribution
to your future self so a lot of people
that don't realize they're
subconsciously chasing adrenaline
because it turns into dopamine and want
to make their life you know or just
habitually nature and nurture only know
how to self-destruct and put themselves
in situations that recreate their
childhood circumstances and the
neurochemicals that they grew up in
epigenetically or from well I mean to
dumb it down a little bit is to I don't
want to feel bad
I've running I've been running from
feeling bad since I first felt bad
because I went from being this beautiful
kid that everybody loved and everybody
doted over to somebody being really mean
to me for no reason and I didn't
understand why like you were your own
bully and it made no I knew who it was
it was you know my first stepfather who
you know physically hit me and told me
to see what I mean so it's like you know
this these feelings I remember it I
remember being the the life of the party
being loved you know all this stuff and
then I remember my mom meeting this guy
and how great he was and get moving out
of my grandmother's house and three
bedroom with 13 people into having my
own room I remember going into my room
and there was a toy box that had toys in
it a desk with pen paper erasers in it I
remember looking at the light fixture
and I was turning the light on and off
and I was like is this my light and
they're like that's your light and I I
sat there in the room going I have my
own light I remember there was a bean
bag there was a little TV a black and
white TV and I remember being like I I
mean holy shit cut to
being in the bean bag
falling asleep waking up hearing noise
going into the kitchen seeing my sister
crying seeing my mother being punched in
the stomach seeing him throw a phone at
my sister's head because she was trying
to call my uncles to get help and then
my mother grabbing my sister and me
bringing her into the room me holding
the door shut him kicking the door open
me flying against the door smashing my
head sliding down pretending to be dead
because I thought if I pretended to be
dead he wouldn't hurt me and then him
going get up you fucking pussy that
didn't hurt that much
I is he still alive I don't know I don't
know but I remember that
but I feel I forgive this is my brain
I'm like if he isn't tell me where he
lives that's my job I already forgave
him because you know why it was done to
him
it was done to him
it's not his fault it was done to him so
the thing that I have
my responsibility right now is to love
my son
all the time and love doesn't always
switch which for me you know I had an
um I don't I have people women in my
life that were Tethered to this man that
are he's still alive so I have to be
careful yeah um
uh even though I'm not protecting him I
just I'm protecting myself and everyone
else involved it took me a long time I
mean I used to go on Howard Stern and
just fucking blather all my business and
I just thought I was being authentic and
like not having me I did the same shit I
did it to my sister yeah you know I and
we're working through our relationship
now but I went on and I I grew up around
so many lies you know I'm learning as an
adult omissions are also lies because
kids know everything and no one no you
know there was a lot of
I don't even where do you fall on even
Santa I remember being like why we just
lie to kids Santa Tooth Fairy I knew
there were lies I was like just tell me
and if because kids know the truth and
what happens is if an adult consistently
lies to them they start to just doubt
their own reality and assume they're
nuts they default to because they can't
it's too annihilating to the psyche to
think that your primary caretaker who
provides for you is flawed so you must
go well I'm plawed but I am very flood I
actually raise my voice I have a temper
but I've given my son
acknowledge it it's fine my son I
actually me and my wife got in a fight
the other day
um you know whatever growth opportunity
I don't know she she I told you I have a
shirt that I didn't finish it but I said
I have a shirt that says be weak
apologize that's my therapist I love it
my therapist thing that he says
apologize but only when you're ready to
do it without going sorry right say what
you mean mean what you say don't say it
well I was like dude you want me to
appall he's like just I go you want me
to be weak he goes yes that's what he
tells me I want you to be weak I want
you to be weak I don't want you to
apologize to your wife being weak is the
strongest thing but we'll call it 100 so
I mean well anyways me and my wife we
got into it a little bit but of course
we're it's a relationship it's a
marriage it's not I'm not her parent
she's not my mom so may I ask really
quick just really quick we'll get back
to the wolf pack so horses the way that
they work out things it's really just
it's just setting boundaries and
resetting boundaries and they constantly
have to test each other so so we tend to
not think of ourselves as animals we're
animals but what animals do is they test
each other so it has to happen
constantly especially as you get older
testing you still there you still
neurologically sound can I still trust
you it's fine if the answer is no but
then I just need to know how much more
weight to carry at least for today so
when you watch horses in the wild
they'll bite at each other they'll kind
of kick at each other and then they
forget right away it's literally just I
understand that but this is not that
this is me this is my my bullshit that
still exists you know I I raise my voice
because it protects me you understand I
could say get the I'll fucking you know
what I mean I'll fucking kill you you
wanna fight and hopefully the person
will back down when I was a younger not
a girl from Boston no but no but uh you
picked up my mother my mother's the same
person you know what are you screaming
my mother would yell and scream you know
what I mean it was just kind of the
thing that they didn't know any better
back then and women are the most
vulnerable they have to it's like small
dogs bark the most so I I have I'm I'm
learning to get this out of my life but
I do I still my wife will go down I'll
which makes me go up so if I go up she
goes down which makes it go up which
makes her go down so literally the
problem is we just keep doing this and
then I fucking have to leave I gotta
that's romantic though so my son the
other day literally we had this little
thing and I went into the thing the shed
my little whatever man shed and I came
back into my someone said can I talk to
you for a second I was like yeah he goes
in the other room
I was like okay and then he sits me down
he goes dad not in your tree house no in
the bedroom in the main room in the
master bedroom and he goes um
you hurt my feelings when you raise your
voice to my mother
and I I and he I I didn't I didn't say a
thing I wanted to like that instinctual
I just sat there and I let him talk
as long and I just I'm gonna let him
talk until he's done and my son can be
wordy so this could be a long time
so he he goes uh he he goes I you know
when you talk to her like that it hurts
my feelings it doesn't make me feel good
I know you guys fight I know you guys
sometimes just but you can't you can't
do that anymore and I love her and she
loves me and I love you and you love me
and you love her and she loves you
and we have to love each other and that
and then he goes mom and can we know I
want to hug it out wow I wanna can we
just hold each other right now and give
you and now
this is from what she and myself have
taught him wow this is from us wow that
he has and I was so proud that he said
wow because I say this is what I've
grown up you're a fucking asshole I
fucking hate you I'm pissed at you
you're a dickhead fuck her fuck him fuck
them
in reality what I really say and you
hurt my feelings so much that you're the
only person that can get me to this
place yeah and he the fact that he
understands that that you know he felt
something and he felt it he didn't run
from it he felt it and expressed it and
asked me to change it and I was fucking
blown away and then the next level to
that for me yeah the black belt I'm not
there yet yeah you know
is as my sister and I are repairing yeah
is like I love you yeah and it will
happen again yep but I will even if it's
one percent better it I I will handle it
better next time
try and thank you for holding him thank
you for calling me out yeah I I like to
pride myself on telling on myself and
getting ahead of it yeah but you know
it's it's rage is a very real hypnotic
like when those internal you know this
would have started for you in utero so
if our mom's epigenetic imprinting
um basically
pretends that we the whatever so like a
crack baby you know that term's not
great but when a baby is uh exposed to
uh crack cocaine I don't know the
difference I've never done cracker game
so I don't know it's the same thing my
mayor was Marion Barry in DC we voted
for a crack if we re-elected him yeah I
love that guy so I just know our mayor
did crack and I know you weren't
supposed to and so um so because I'm
looking into adoption and Appalachia and
the foster care system there because
there's babies being born into the
opioid crisis and you were born addicted
to whatever is in the bloodstream of the
mom that includes neurochemicals
adrenaline cortisol so if you are in
utero
while you're you know what are the
chances your mom while pregnant with you
wasn't a little stressed out producing
adrenaline cortisol 100 so we're born
addicted to it so it's this is my mom
was 18. she was 15 when she had my
sister
so yeah it helps me when genetics loads
the gun environment pulls the trigger so
it's like when you're like radical
accountability with that said none of
this is your fault like somewhere in
between and it's just finding the people
around you that have the patience and
won't take it personally because they
know who you are when you're not
high on the drug that you inherited the
addiction to honestly and you have that
and that's well I gotta I got a woman
this beautiful woman that understands me
and that she actually
um has been there and and helped me
evolve
you know from a very what a gift to her
she's I mean a gift I feel like it's it
it's the our son
right
has has something that I always wanted
and I think my wife always wanted a big
dick
he's got a bigger piece of me which is
uncomfortable that's what I've heard
well I got a nice one though since I
lost weight it's come back oh but you
can see it now I can see it but it's you
know it's two hands again
okay I had a thumb and two fingers for a
while now it's bing bing
um but he he's got
he's got knowledge he's got cool parents
right but he's got he's got a family
that starts at love
you know it doesn't always look like a
Norman Rockwell paper no sometimes it
goes shut the fuck up yeah wow yeah
sorry that's not I just my parenting
style is look I was raised by Virginia
women that had animals and no kids yeah
and my mom a working single mom so yeah
for me I just we're tough I feel like I
have trauma privilege
when people look at me and they're like
she worked so hard and she's so
successful it's like
it doesn't occur to me to do anything
else because I grew up with three single
badass women that just worked constantly
on farms I was working on farms full
time or I was working my mom took me she
worked at
um in a department store uh she worked
at Bloomingdale's did PR and worked 24
7. so I only saw people working to my
dad was a total animal I'd wake up the
middle of the night if I heard a noise
and he'd be two in the morning working
recopying his phone numbers into
um my mom did a filofax my dad just only
carried around a yellow legal pad and he
would just recopy his notes over and
over again his phone numbers books
and so um you know I would in school
recopy I do take my notes I go home and
I recopy them I go home I didn't have
friends I just recall and played sports
that's the other thing it's like is as I
get older
and not judging anyone but when it comes
to hiring and I don't ever say someone
works for me I say they work with me so
that's the main role we have if I'm
working with you you don't say I work
for you you say you work with me because
we're a team we're a wolf pack right I
see Comics we're all a wolf pack and I
think we've been deluded into believing
we're lone wolves but I think if we were
a pack we're Unstoppable you know but
there's all been all these petty
bullshit within us and spats and you
know no I think you know they kind of
put us against each other like if you if
this was on Comedy Central and your
podcast and then I wouldn't I wouldn't
be on it ever because the person who
booked it or the person that steers you
in directions they wouldn't have me on
it because I don't have this I don't
have that if I was on it they'd say just
don't be you it's like that happened on
my NBC show they were like we want
Whitney Cummings and crystalia just
don't do anything you guys actually do
right I was like the fact that you
booked me is why I'm on it so yeah I
think you're right but also it's like
and look and and and back to sort of the
thing if you don't mind me just tell me
to
if I'm being I know I'm being non-linear
um
is that going back to it was so shocking
to me when or the pandemic when I blew
hair everyone was like Whitney's gone
nuts yeah and I'm like you guys didn't
think I'd gone nuts when I was on NBC
like in commercials like dancing like
about look at my sitcom like that was
nuts you know I was a kid I know what I
was doing I hired as many Comics as I
could obviously crystalline I wrote it
for Chris and me together right you know
because we were best friends and I was
like there's nothing I want to do more
than just how do I find a way to get
paid for us to just do what we're doing
now right before podcasts you had to
create a TV show for each other yeah
yeah you know Christy was on it and you
know Kathy Griffin and I just got to
hire like I just wanted I was poor so I
was like how do I make money
having my most talented friends just be
talented with me and never in a million
years
I guess on some level I knew it would go
but I also didn't because I was like
like I'm not famous no one here's famous
but what I didn't know is that TV at the
time makes Stars so shows of big
celebrity is always tanked for in Litany
of reasons ours only cost like 1.3
million because none of us cost me money
we'd have quotes you know and I was
writing it creating it I mean I had a
great staff but I hired Comics Dan Levy
was on it you know and so um it was
really cheap and then Chris and I tested
through the roof yeah so we tested it
was I I don't know I'm sure this could
be an exaggeration the person that told
me I don't know why they lied to me but
it was one of the highest testing Pilots
ever for NBC so that's why we got that
100 million and then I'm all of a sudden
I'm in Times Square on billboards and
posters and I haven't earned my stripes
yet with the Stan the rider die stand-up
Community yeah that's a different thing
though I mean Billy Burr had a go pilot
six months into New York City with car
seat Warner you know what I mean it's
like sure that that's a that's a
different you know
um I just get insecure that people
forgot that I was like a con a touring
doing 80 cities a year I opened for
Bobby Lee and Steve Byrne and was doing
six spots a night with no car like and I
don't want to brag and but to me it was
always like I'll learn but the Optics
like Madison Sinclair said going back to
her she goes I was like why did everyone
think I was so crazy when I dyed my hair
blue they were like she goes it would
have been like if Jay Leno got a nose
ring yep I was like yeah what yeah if I
saw Jay Leno with a nose ring and a
fucking kitten I'd be like see what's up
with you because I I realized how but I
also didn't know you which is funny no
one did I hit it I I only showed the
part of me you've actually come out let
me say something about you you've
actually reached out you've actually
come out and started hanging and and
making yourself available to for other
people like I saw you with Giannis doing
this show and I was like fucking a and I
called stay with me he saved my life two
pitbulls went at each other and I
usually have it under control as much as
I can if it wasn't for Giannis I would
probably have lost a finger wait what do
you use his Greek voice no he was back
he was back he's a real fucking man yes
I told him to take his shoes off I was
like hang out take his shoes off he's
like no I'll keep him on I was like
hanging out we're hanging we're watching
some football downstairs or Greek food
my friend Nick kurzon Boston guy yeah
um uh and uh I had two female pits here
at the same time that I just I wasn't
you know my definition of insanity doing
the same thing over and over again
expecting a different result I have a
really hard time just resigning to the
fact that you know maybe this is the
same case with women in comedy which is
why I have to stop trying so hard to
make all the girls be friends or make
them all like me two female pits if they
have a lot of trauma yeah it's always
gonna just get sketchy and there was a
puppy in the house in my ridgeback pit
went for the other staffy and the other
staffy even though she pretends to be
obsequious she'll fight she needs to
obsequious
I mean I don't know who you think I am
but you know what I'm you know what I
mean I don't you don't know what that
means I don't think you can't deduce for
contact clues all right first of all the
fact you're throwing deduce in there too
is is I know what deduce means you know
what it all means I don't know what that
one means you pretending to be dumb is
charming you're not you're not not
fooling anyone I was in I am not I am I
am uh people smart I'll size a
motherfucker up if you guys watch watch
killbox and you tell me who's smarter
and if you say me please unsubscribe no
no no please don't you're very smart I'm
just telling you the way that you craft
this words wise you're gonna pretend
you're just you're he's gonna you're
it's gonna seem like he's just making
amplify the way that he fucking puts
images in your head or unlike anything
I've seen thank you very much but I
don't watch I mean I haven't watched
every stand-up special ever I'm like you
know
catching up on some overrated ones but
um so to he heard it from the other room
he just heard and I wasn't screaming
because that just would have made them
more defensive and he just ran in yeah
and he's had pits and he what you
normally do is put the finger in the
butthole
I'm sorry I'm I'm sorry I didn't I
thought to break up a pitbull fight
or any dog lifting the back legs I
thought that was only with Puerto Rican
guys was
now it's only with Nick Swardson
trying to blow your dog listen to me so
it was almost adorable
um but listen you have to stick that's a
thing see that scar yeah I do so that's
from um putting my finger in a dog's
mouth during a dog fight to stop it so
you put it in the asshole so you want to
do one this is this is another thing
that you've told me it was bitten off
okay it's sewn back on this is another
thing you've told me today that I hope
is true because if I'm in New York City
and I see two dogs going at it you're
gonna do nothing and I stick my finger
up the dog's asshole don't do it unless
it's one of yours or your kids nearby
okay so they don't get involved at all
okay so never stick my dog my finger in
a dog's asshole unless it's my dog or my
kids are involved or it's your thing
what if an old lady is in trouble
in a park it was two pimples do I stick
my finger in the dog's asshole that's my
ear like after it was something yeah I
can show it to you before it was sewn up
so if and I would just pick up the old
lady and remove her first what if the
dogs are attached to her
then yes you would put your finger up
the asshole and what does that do it
basically makes them turn around because
if you that actually makes me Arch my
back and go oh God so
what if the dog is like me by the way
only in a certain context if someone did
that to you in Central Park is that what
you would do I would still go oh my God
does it depend on whose finger it was
yeah oh my God this is what I love about
being able to do podcasts one of the
many things besides everything you've
listed is Like Comics like when we
perform such a small fraction of who we
are it's our scripted self like I know
we write on stage and improvise but it's
like our brains are so granular like we
make generalizations for a living but
actually we're like
were not generalization people when
you're like oh all men are like this I'm
like no it's just because I only have 60
Minutes up
I just hit my finger on Ronnie
Dangerfield's thing fuck you frame not
Rodney get no respect no respect for my
fingers they're all fucked up anyway um
this show is sponsored by betterhelp now
I know that in the past I've talked a
lot about how important it is to go to
therapy I don't like the word therapy
because I feel like it's overused it's
like the word feminist like it's very
unclear what it means you know you talk
to people they're like well I'm in
therapy and then it's revealed that it's
just like
their cousin does Reiki
in Tampa and you're like that's not I
don't think that counts but then they
think they're healed and then you have
to like
deal with their white elephant gift
situation at the Christmas party which
is like a Fleshlight and I know you're
gonna say but I don't have time to go to
therapy
if you go to therapy if you do better
help however whatever you need a week
you'll you'll know you will save time
because when we
attune with people and share with
someone appropriate instead of telling
all our friends our drama and I think
he's doing that we cost ourselves time
down the line right so we oh we free up
our bandwidth when we are able to have
Grace which comes from admitting our
deepest darkest most embarrassing
secrets and asking for help to people
that are qualified to give us help right
and I'm telling you it has freed up
so much time to just take that hour of
self-care and get ahead of it so
betterhelp.com is the world's largest
therapy service has matched three
million people professionally it used to
be 1 million when we started working
with that member okay
um three million people with
professionally licensed and vetted
therapists available 100 online I am
sure acupuncture works it's not therapy
I'm sure reikia does what it needs fine
I'm sure stretch it's this is licensed
therapists
that it's not it's not the lady that
does the puts amethysts on your neck
that's not that's not we're doing here
okay it is also affordable fill out a
brief questionnaire to match with a
therapist things aren't clicking you can
easily switch to a new therapist anytime
uh it just couldn't be simpler no
waiting rooms no traffic no endless
searching for the right therapists learn
more save 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com Whitney if this isn't a
good New Year's resolution I don't know
what is better help hllp.com
Whitney it will make you be able to talk
to your parents without screaming at
them
so we get to show people I think this
why people like it like we are the call
what you want mentally ill OCD AC all of
it you get to see our brains just right
at its For Better or Worse
um can I really quick just unless you
want to do you want to continue with
that no would it go ahead because there
was two things I want to continue number
one about my face I okay yeah I'm fine
with that what I'm I'm following you
thanks I like following you lead
membership
you're the wolf pack right you're the
leader of the wolf I am part of your
pack right now so that brings us to the
story of the wolf pack so yeah when you
bring
um at risk there's not a better word for
it at the moment if you have one let me
know see in the comments at risk youth
so say kids that like you when you were
9 10 11 12 sure abusive stepfather
getting into drugs they're in juvenile
detention okay they go to a place called
wolf connection if the rehab or
detention Place animal therapy it's the
most underutilized medicine we have sure
I agree with the education which is I'm
going to throw this out there and get in
trouble but I don't care because I know
that I'm eventually going to be right
about this which is the African-American
black whatever Community I'm nervous yep
so am I okay is what we did to them
besides in addition to slavery and that
subjugation okay was because dogs were
trained to hunt them right there's still
ancestral trauma and a learned imprinted
instinctual kind of fear of dogs okay
and what would make a black mother you
know maybe feel safer about her black
kid walking down the street than if they
had a dog
so the fact that you know you br I hear
a police officer breaking into a black
woman's house and killing her with no
warrant and it's the wrong house I'm
like where was the dog
the therapeutic benefits of dogs the
protective benefits of dogs is I think
one of such a disgrace in our country
because if we can heal that Association
because it's so recent I mean their dogs
were please for uh criminals uh convicts
too and they and to just I agree with
that so if if we could heal the
relationship there's a couple amazing
programs that bring rescue dogs into
prisons and and these you know the
inmates are able to train the dogs and
work and learn responsibility because
it's not about you
it's about them and words make us trick
us yeah and non-verbal relationships
with animals help us with trust yes they
don't need anything from you and you get
to if you've been abused neglected
um being with animals they need nothing
from you and the healing benefits of
just being around an animal that needs
nothing from you is already a place
where you can cry they don't judge you
they don't care what you do for a living
that's already so
cut two that's a different thing I don't
know what to do about that but it's an
idea that I think I'll you know someone
that hears this will reach out and know
who should
um take the lead on it but it's an
observation that I think only a white
person could
you know and I think it's just for me
I'm always trying to just be brave as a
white woman that has privilege with just
saying shit that's going to get me in
trouble even if it helps I'll be fine
right
um
so
um although wolves are in
um they're dense right but they're uh
what's the wire that is on basketball
courts in New York
it's not
chicken wire
what the fuck what's a fence that's wire
called a fence yeah but if it's like
that would have dogs behind it or I'm
sorry my brain is like a little mush
it's a fence but like the okay but
they're not it's not like a picket fence
so I'm trying to no it's a fence it's
our job as Comics I feel like to paint a
picture with words and I'm I'm failing
it's a metal fence metal fence how's
that it's little triangles yeah like the
metal fence there is a word for it but I
just said you went growing up it's a
fence yeah you look at it that's
offensive so it's fenced in down when
it's a wooden fence you add wood
dude wood fence so you would anything
else if it's a metal triangle little
fence that's a fence see sometimes but
in Virginia I would think uh barbed wire
fence
you can do so I don't want people to
think it was just barbed wire fence
right no barb wire is barbed wire on top
of the fence got it so fence the default
is
crisscrosses okay yeah right I think so
okay yeah metal fence sorry metal fence
I'm trying to just after what's your
special I am like so ashamed at how like
bad my word choices are you're out you
fucking you're not you have a holy shit
vocabulary
it's it's making me feel bad
unbelievable the words you chose and I
think the next level of actually me
being a better comedian is being more
prosaic and not using bigger words I
only I like I like quote-unquote big
words because I like I'm a perfectionist
and for every
two small words there's always a word
for everything right so I was kind of
alone a lot as a kid and I would I was
so insecure that I was not smart enough
because my dad really valued
intelligence and I would read the
dictionary
and study and if there was always a word
I didn't know I would look it up and I
would just drill it into my head I'd
write it on my hand drill it in my head
and I had this incredible teacher
um uh Dr Abraham where I went to high
school and everyone hated her and I kind
of did too but she said there was never
I just don't want to take credit for
this even though I kind of wanted to for
a second there so very good is great
very great is awesome very awesome you
never need the word very unless it's for
Choice like so I just like the idea that
all these words have meanings and we
just don't use them a lot like I it
makes me feel like horses like neglected
horses like I feel like like responsible
for these neglected words I know that
I'm in grief you guys I'm grieving I
feel like I would dependent with words I
think I love words too but I even make
up words that I like I use Flip Flip I
love in my active dude I flipped it over
and I love that people know what I'm
saying
I cannot stop saying memes
member eggs in the first like 10 minutes
of the special evolves into membe my
favorite is yada you're mine you say
that on your podcast
[Music]
I can't stop saying it yeah saying are
you out of your mind to someone it's
such a heart it's such a rough someone
like Bobby Kelly saying get out of your
mind it's like it's a rhetorical
question like what are you supposed to
do with that and you just hold it like
am I supposed to really answer like that
is like you're cornering someone in a
way that's so funny to watch it's just
that it is a weird Boston uh the way we
talked with you out of your fucking
money on your fucking mind is more of uh
yes my best friend is and he goes guy
hey guy he calls me guy my best friend
is from Boston to kurzon yeah we dated
for a couple years 20 years ago and
we're to stick a thieves and so I've
like
because I pulled a shirt out of his
drawer put it on he was like
really yeah what was it I bet you know
a shirt
why would a guy from Boston Celtic shirt
Larry Bird no more no more oh yeah
that's a big one too it was like his no
Marshall oh is it actual no martial you
can't fucking touch and it had like yeah
and it was the one that won the game oh
no shit but he's we still I mean yeah
it's a weird thing
I dated a Patriots fan who
by accident every time they won I was
sitting on a certain part of the couch
yep
two years later he's with someone new
he's like can you just come by Foreign
my stepdad who I loved when my mother
remarried to a beautiful guy he would
make me
um I would have to stay in the kitchen
if I went to the other room and they got
a touchdown you'd have to stay where you
were in the house wherever you were you
couldn't come back you had to watch the
game from that place sure it's just a
Boston thing and is that would that be
called Superstition or just
superstitious so yeah
okay so the fencing so there's a wolf
pack it's about 12 wolves right we made
it back to Wolf Pack we're back we're
always on track I am I'm part of the
pack I trust you I think these tangents
I do not I'm fucking with you I told you
I'm here that's what it's I if I haven't
earned your trust I will I you got it
I'm fucking I'm here with you so this is
the thing about when people think I'm
crazy it's like based on a snippet I
agree with you you know but
I'm really big on going okay if it's a
woman that has a lot of thoughts and
gets bored easily and wants to make
something interesting and wants to make
sure we pay off all the things we set up
because we're wired for completion so
all the things that everyone's heard us
start the story now we got to finish it
because I owe that to them sure
so um
um let's say okay so there's 12 uh
wolves that's a wolf pack and they're
all in their fenced in dens and the
at-risk youth come right and they say
Okay so the first thing we do is we go
so this is Bo the one the wolf I
sponsored she passed away this is bone
Bo had a father that um that used to
beat him up real bad would bite at him
when he was just a little kid would bite
his sister would bite it as Mom and he
always tried to fight back but he
couldn't protect him you know so that's
Bo he's a little bit angry and he tries
to beat up on other people but it's just
because he's sad you know yeah okay and
this is you know
Athena right she's I'm just making these
up I love it whatever and you say to the
boys like hey so which one's your
favorite
and one will go Bo yeah
and then you know who he is so no kid
wants to say or has nor should they need
to right my dad abuses my mom or my
stepdad abuses my mom and my sister and
there's nothing I can do so I'm fucking
angry all right and I want to go sell
drugs and I want to kill this guy and
I'll punch anyone that fucking talks to
me sideways especially adults that say
calm down you're fine it's not fine I'm
watching my mom get people so that's
like when you talk through that metaphor
why do you like both so much yeah well
Bo but like it's not Bo's fault yeah so
just and then you can start having a
dialogue that isn't fraught with all
this
human
shit yeah and then he can go hang out
with Bo right and go what's it what
should Bo do instead of attacking
someone else like what would be
well maybe if he just could control his
anger in certain ways maybe if he just
ran around a lot and you go cool
and then and then you go like well maybe
you should we should just play some
sports maybe we should run track you
know it starts to be an end to be able
to communicate in a way where you're not
expecting some kid
to talk to some psychiatrist or you know
what I'm saying that's going to make
assumptions and just be a privileged
asshole you know yeah and I think I
think all that stuff helps
but you know I I've been thinking about
it lately like I look at my life and I
look at you know I got sober
I got arrested I went to jail and I got
sober
and that was a lot I didn't you know but
something happened
something
um in the universe somewhere ever
happened to me
where I was done
at 15 in a GL cell Rochester New York on
my knees would you call that a rock
bottom or is that too it was a rock
bottom I guess but it was more of a
I don't know something if it was going
to work I would have something happened
all the other people I knew it didn't
happen for but it happened for me
Miracle but I think that a lot of people
it never happens for never happens
before but I think that farm
had a lot to do with me
finding feeling
um real happiness can I say something
else that's really witchcrafty shit I
know y'all this is where I'm gonna lose
you
okay
there's electricity in the Earth
right like our electrons I'm I'm with
you so it's like I love New York I wish
I could live there yeah it just weakens
me personally okay because we're on
pavement right and we're wearing shoes
right so we're kind of blocking our
Earth's ability to re-energize us and
balance um I don't disagree with that I
like I told you before
I bought the re one of the reasons I
bought land in New Hampshire and and and
put the tiny house on it and I spent
this is the first year we spent two
months up there we spent the summer up
there as a family Sandler's from there
right in Sarah Silverman Manchester
which is like an hour down I'm more up
in the mountains in the Lake Region but
there was something about every morning
I would get up and get my dog and mind
you I just got the surgery
uh you know it's 350 pounds but every
morning I would get up get the dog and
go for this walk in the country up these
roads and it um
you know and be in the woods and then be
on a lake and then you know
um
you know uh there's something about it
that actually it's a fucking made me
better and quiet like we don't we talk
about pollution I know
Greta toomberg knock yourself out and
all I don't I'm not going to weigh in on
on that
actually I'm working on this bet I prom
I'm too embarrassed to tell you what it
is or I feel like I have to before I say
something that might accidentally be
funny
that that being
like trying to fix climate change this
is a comedian at the very Inception of a
joke idea of like they you know the sort
of alt left alt left and ALT right both
idiots it's just self-righteous
indignation addicts I think we'll look
back and go oh there was a epidemic of
self-righteous indignation where people
intentionally misunderstand what you're
saying it's the new religion great in
order to be justified in um just you
know and so
they say like well global warming or
climate change is a war on poor people
and if you've been poor you know like I
wouldn't mind a little less black ice in
the winter like because that's so bad
like have you ever taken the bus like
poor people like can it get a little
warmer that'd be fine 800 I wouldn't
freak out yeah there was a little bit
less ice
um but
the we really do and I think it's you
know I I don't blame the people
that did it it's capitalism and its
American ambition but um
the medicine that's right beneath us you
know for the dirt animals water it's
right nature is to me at 52. is the
thing that fucking uh um cleanses my
spirit number one way to relieve anxiety
yeah and everyone's running around I
have anxiety anxiety I'm not saying it's
not true but have you tried a couple
things first first of all having an
animal around you so we've evolved to
sleep more deeply if you hear a dog
breathing next to you yeah makes perfect
sense right and then seeing periphery
so seeing a horizon first thing in the
morning
deactivates your amygdala and you stop
producing cortisol your vagal nerve
which goes right under your chin here if
it's up that means we're looking we're
safe why would I feel stress up here
this
biologically means we're hiding
protecting ourselves this means produce
cortisol be fucking awake adrenaline
you're being attacked something bad's
happening and this is the same position
we do on a computer
so this is telling our body things are
we're in danger no this
right so I get to wake up in the morning
and see a mountain it's changed my life
to not look out and just see well I
think but I I think it's more than I
think it's okay I don't know way more
than that I don't know about that but I
think about the fact when for me and I'm
waking up in the morning waking up in
the morning sitting on my bench
and there's nothing
there's nothing but noises that I don't
know where they are or what it is noise
pollution that's what I was gonna say
it's like these little birds and the the
Leafs and is that an animal and it you
know and and walking I would walk out in
the woods in the morning because I have
a few Acres that go goes into 500 Acres
Nature Preserve one thing I can ask the
one paranoia
what I'm I got when I went and did the
Hamptons uh Performing Arts Center
whatever recently yeah I got a tick in
right next to my pussy it had been there
for two days
because the thin the crevice next to
your pussy that's where they it's the
thinnest skin thank God I don't have
pubes I never would have found it I mean
a little ring around it I had to go on
antibiotics for four weeks Avril Lavigne
remember when she just disappeared for
two she had what how did you get a tick
in your pussy at a comedy club I was out
God forbid I walked from the car to the
house was I gonna I bet that's not the
woods went to Tim Dylan's house and he's
trying to sabotage me he probably put it
there I mean yeah I I don't know where
you I mean get a tick on your puss it do
you wear underwear they jump yeah I mean
I went outside in my bathing suit and I
was walking around I went for a run I
went for a bike ride
so how did you find the tick I changed
my clothes I went to Baltimore who took
it off
me I know I'm from Virginia you bite the
fucking head off and then you burn it
you you bit the head off well yeah you
take it off you bite the head off oh not
for you didn't bite it off dad you know
how flexible I would content concept
that's a tick tock
um that I'm gonna get so the Lyme
disease thing is the oh maybe I'm just
ignorant but I can kill a fucking
rattlesnake on site nothing really
scares me an invisible vampire that can
make your neurology away from you I
don't fuck with when I go on the woods I
mean I mean I don't worry about it I
wear pants and I we spray you know you
do the things you suppose when you go in
the woods you're supposed to do certain
things you have to go on a hike you
can't just go out like Ari shaffir when
women go in the woods it's mostly to get
murdered by their husbands well when you
go in the woods we're very aware we wear
pants and boots and certain things so
you don't get ticks we don't want ticks
our dog got ticks but yeah
every time we come back everybody gets
checked okay there we go I don't care I
what if you're in a fight and you're
like fuck you I'm not you know and you
forget I'm just I just and it's fight
with the tick like whoever would check
you my wife we don't we don't get a
fights like that okay even if you're mad
she's gonna secure your butt cheeks even
if you're in a I'm not gonna let if I
have a if I have a tick in my asshole
I'm gonna get Lyme disease you'd rather
just get it
rather get Lyme disease and then you'll
be tired you'll hate it I'm fine with
that there's no way
in my life
that I would let my wife go into my
asshole feel it yourself to make sure
you don't have one I would do it myself
but there's no way I would ever say
honey please check check my ass but the
only thing meaner is to get Lyme disease
and be a vegetable and then she has to
take care of you but I I would allow her
not that she's not with you only for
your looks she's not but you'd lose your
brain my wife is not for looks or money
she looks she is purely love but I
remember to orgasm I went from February
2008 didn't get much money for that
anyways actually did the whole thing for
free
um how you doing listen taking my my
life doesn't go in my asshole ever I no
I I don't do that either but unless if I
know there could be a tick in there I'll
probably
listen two things I'd let her do weird
shit too like sexual stuff I'd let her
do to my asshole but to check for
something like a doctor or like I will
just feel just like there's a bump I
don't want you in there scientifically
okay I'm just doing it dirty wise if she
wants to get down there ask Greg
Fitzsimmons about Lyme disease I just
remembered who it was his mom was on
drip antibiotics for like 11 years
really these are little fucking
motherfuckers that I know covid yes was
bad of course but Lyme disease is just
this constant thing now you get me
freaked out I mean you've ruined maybe
you should be freaked out I don't want
to be freaky okay well I think the more
you know the less freaked out you'll be
is that an ABC or an NBC commercial you
know yeah I still work for NBC I'm still
under there ticks don't bother me I we
we check for them but I like nature
itself to me here's what it is I'm
afraid of it
I'm afraid of it christianism just a
giant to me murder sure I'm afraid of it
the ocean I want nothing to do with
Woods I love love the woods me too I
want I'm afraid of it I'm actually I'm
shooting a show
I I've talked about this before uh it's
called comedy camp where I'm taking
comedians into the woods like it's alone
meets like Comedians in Cars I'm taking
Russell Peters Jim Norton best-selling
up into the woods we'll do fine five
days no phones can I do one no anything
of absolutely yeah I'd love for you to
do it absolutely it's five days you know
that I'm like of West Virginia like I
will I'm Blair Witch bitch I mean yeah I
can make fires yeah there's nothing up
there though there's no craft service
there's no
nothing you still think I'm like a
Hollywood no bathroom
yeah I really watch my Instagram you'd
see that IP outside I understand that
but only I only do it to scare off uh
deer so that where the coyotes you know
like shitting all that stuff so it's
it's all that I don't shit
yeah I'm a lady
can I I would love to do that if you'll
have me no pressure I would love to have
I'm in a weird place where sometimes I
think that people don't want to ask me
because they don't like me and then
later they'll be like I just didn't
think you'd say yes so I'm trying to put
myself out there and just go I'd love to
do it if you'll have me no pressure
because you know why that is though
because you're you came onto the scene
became very successful went and worked
and then Mary Katz was my manager and
then came back and then come back and
now you're actually available to us
which is awesome but I think I was in
the it's almost like getting out of
Scientology or something like I was in
the throes of Hollywood and like I
really that machine at the time it was
like it was like that's how you make it
you get on The Tonight Show and I think
I was a little bit in the relics of like
there's I don't trust my own Talent
enough and all right maybe I hadn't
actually earned the ability to just lean
on stand up only you know even by my
I've done five specials even my third
special I was like not good enough yet I
still need to use this Hollywood Machine
I don't think we're ever good enough
though because I don't feel I everybody
I think I don't feel good enough I think
as Comics it's like are you are we ever
satisfied no I think we're always like
fuck I'll go watch David tell and go
fuck what you said what did you hear on
Rogan he wasn't even trying to be funny
fuck you David tell funny he says the
funniest shit I've ever heard when he's
just talking yeah even when he's he said
um so funny he goes you know when he
goes on podcast he doesn't really like
yuck get up you know the way I try to
like do my song and dance the Rogan fans
love it when I try to force jokes down
their throats
um they learn that the hard way you just
shut the fuck up and talk and listen and
don't try to Pedal your wares for them
um they fucking smell the Dust
aspiration and I was always very
desperate I think when I first went on
there and uncomfortable instead of just
talking to my friend I'd be like oh I
have to perform oh Joe's so easy to talk
to too
but it's like but it's like this I mean
it goes it just goes I just didn't I
just put pressure on us unnecessarily
pressure on myself because I didn't
believe in myself yet um right and trust
that the people to fuck with you fuck
with you and the people that don't don't
just be authentic and you'll find the
right ones yes you'll never get everyone
why would you want to and don't read the
comments or do and just like send them
love yeah
send them love yeah you know
um I didn't sign up how to make your day
if hating me makes your day it used to
make me feel good to call someone an
asshole
you know so if I made your day by saying
look at this fucking annoying cunt and
you feel a little better about yourself
I did my job today but what did Dave say
Dave said
he goes yeah you know the um pandemic uh
the and we are gonna wrap up soon
because I'm being selfish with you
um uh I'm just having the best time
um he said you know the outdoor dining
stuff in New York yeah he goes yeah
they're just keeping them up the outdoor
dining is still there it's this wood you
get in there I feel like I'm in a Manger
they were talking about Impractical
Jokers uh and uh Bert's Cruise I'm gonna
do Bert Crushers cruise this year um
bring some family and stuff and um is he
doing a cruise
fuck
and so um we just roasted him on only
fans so I've like a trillion jokes about
it that I'm not gonna do
um but uh he goes uh he broke a towel
goes oh Bert yeah doing the cruise yeah
he goes I guess that's where all comedy
eventually ends up the ocean
dude is the best the way he thinks is
just beyond he's the best Quinn I watch
Quinn but a towel will still go up at
two in the morning he's still so I just
go if the greats every time I see Bill
Burr you a tell before sets after sets
you're like
you know I'm like oh that's how it
should be the grades should just be like
nailed it like what great comic if
everything come off stage you're just
like fucking killed it they're like fuck
I now realize this is a good thing I
thought it was disappointing producers
for the longest time who did my special
Marty colliner who directed my HBO
special in the second Comedy Central one
where you know everyone was doing like
videoing you before you went on stage
and after you went like these behind the
scenes like bits yeah of you getting
ready first but I think it's like just
do 60 Minutes of Comedy yep back then
for Comedy Central
you know what I would say to people
Comics now we're like well no we've
decoder stand up up into one minute
chunks fuck that
dude Comedy Central it was 43 minutes
yep they would cut you after six minutes
commercial break
eight minutes after that yep commercial
so we were cut up and you didn't get to
they would just cut it wherever they
wanted cut it wherever you want it and
they play it once and then another one
on Saturday and you go by unless you
rape somebody and then they played it
Non-Stop and then um exactly so
cutting up to a minute at least we're
able to control what minute it is you
know so I would just watch my fucking
jokes cut up and I'm like of course
people don't think I'm funny this is not
how I would have at all done this had I
known it was going to be cut up this way
because I was trying to tell if a Artful
story
and do you ever know that I forgot where
I am but can you tell yeah okay for 100
yeah but you are the the the wolf pack
later so I'm with you but the best thing
you can do to keep people trusting you
is to just say you don't know if you're
lost and just go I mean I know where I'm
going right I just if you want me to
finish that story
yeah you don't but I think that we've
gone a lot of places so I feel like
we've got into a car
and I do this with my wife sometimes and
we just drove
so the
camera was as soon as I came off stage
was going to catch the moment after
right you know and the moment after her
is going to be like oh my God I just
came off stage yes yeah and I came off
and no I looked like I should have
looked when my mom died three days ago I
mean I looked
crestfallen yeah because it was the
showman couldn't go better
to everyone else fuck another great word
by the way crestfallen I mean Crest
falling it's a good one I don't even
know I know what it means I think but
it's Royal
I mean you should the only person that's
broken the only person that should use
that word is if you own a dragon
that is that that's how epic that word
Crest foil wow Fallen Fallen fast Fallen
Crest Fallen
etymology etiology because it's like
every word right you know we all know
Latin if you just sink my my special
um me and Louie that was an empty Place
created Coastal Coastal creatives in in
um and um the stage is perfect Saint
Pete blank stage uh Petersburg Florida
Saint Pete
where's that St Petersburg yes by Tampa
yes oh no nice uh Scientology Center
based there right near near there right
exactly so we great comedy place we
built that I told him I want Elvis's
Comeback Special 68 Comeback Special wow
wow and he said to me we can do it in
New York for a very cheap at one of the
clubs and we'll have one of these local
guys do it or we could do it
uh your way and I go I want to it needs
to be special it needs the place needs
to be something in it right and I said I
want this and he was like all right fuck
it I'm in I'm in let's do it your way
and
we built this it's a it's a 10 by 10
stage 12 inches off the ground
um and I wanted every shot you see to
have people
you know I didn't want that front thing
I wanted everywhere you go to see people
having a good time you know what I love
at first I got nervous because I was
like you know that when people sometimes
in these specials they'll do a reaction
shot of the audience and then you see
like a Ross Perot shirt and you're like
fuck this is gonna date my spout you
know they've got a Dallas Cowboys Super
Bowl champion you know for whatever you
were blessed like the gods blessed
there's no asshole that stole stole the
show by wearing every special I go out
first taping someone's in a cowboy hat
they think it's their night yeah you
know because when people come to a
special they're like I'm gonna be on
camera well I had a rule
me or uglier
that's very mean to say about that one
I'm not well that's mean to me because
I'm I think I'm all right it looks like
Charlie saren okay good that's a good
job so so the
um
yeah the the actual stage is basically
replicating Elvis is trying to Elvis's
68 special
um which is he's surrounded we couldn't
do the back but we we did literally
almost all surrounded me uh always but
I was so nervous
um doing this and
20 minutes into my set
some lady almost died
no
yeah it was weird I was I was in it I
was in the pocket I was doing it and um
and then I heard help me oh no help her
and I'm like what I mean I'm I I'm
freaking out and I just your helper
please Bobby
and I heard my name so I knew it was
real like it was
this is a real thing like somebody just
said my fucking name and I'm like what
and I hear help please Bobby Helper and
I looked out and this lady is just
having a fucking seizure during my
special 20 minutes in and doing two two
shows two shows but they stopped it they
stopped the show
got to take this lady out and I'm off
she had Lyme disease I mean it was
fucking tragic I mean this I I'm like
epileptic I don't know yeah we had we
stopped the whole fucking show and we
have but at my point of bringing this up
is after I came off stage which I should
have been like oh my God fucking a I
walked off stage with a an eye headache
and not knowing where I was for the last
fucking 40 minutes of my set ocular
migraine have you ever had ocular
migraines 100 with stress and then I
went back into the room and Lou was like
Hey and I was like fucking no
like it didn't like nobody else saw it
but my brain I'm like I fucking just
like you said I felt it I fuck it I mean
Comics are empaths I know that's like a
word that men don't use but we're a
hypersensitive I know why do we have
that dumb voice
why do women have to give us that much
that's me for women too
that's how I sound I'm in heaven and I
want I I like members I would just do
anything to do this again with you in
any capacity oh it's good coming up I'm
glad I uh I got to come out and do your
podcast I was really excited about it
finish
um the not the edging of all edging
shall we finish a couple things shall we
come sure triple orgy
so I had um I was with uh swartson or
podcasting I don't remember which
episode you can go back and hear it in
case I I don't do it justice um he's
talking about Mark Maron and I'm trying
to like help him along with the story
which is the most patronizing arrogant
thing you can do right I heard one time
yeah whatever so he's talking about
Marin and I'm like yeah so then he came
up to you right and then you know and he
goes can you just let me finish the
story yeah and I'm like well it's just
taking you forever and he goes sorry I'm
not an Adderall mannequin
and then the thing you said about my
face when it was swollen that day yeah
as he goes why are you wearing a
Halloween mask
which is funny on so many levels because
he just means like General Halloween
mask like the one from like the 50s that
every kid got right just a white with
the elastic Staples right yeah you stuck
your tongue through just generally it
would cut your tongue your tongue bleach
so then
um the thing is the only reason I now
because people making fun of my face
saying that I got work done and all this
kind of stuff right I admit everything
I've done because I've gotten fake boobs
you know obviously I talk really in my
four specials I I had to get them fixed
a couple times because I had eating
disorders and my boobs grew in different
sizes my wife's boobs she had fake boobs
and one's bigger than the other now
after the kid they're always
asymmetrical always have been always
will be so it's kind of like
whack-a-mole if you're trying to even
them out okay so is she is it on the I
think she wants them taken out but
usually the dominant hand is going to
have more muscle underneath so you're if
you're right-handed your right boob is
going to be bigger than your left she's
right-handed but it's smaller
interesting left one's bigger but she's
going to get them taken out I think
she's going to go back to her old
boobies I mean that's you know some of
them how long she had them do if it's
she's had them a long time because
you're supposed to take them out every
10 years regardless no she didn't get
him it's over 10 years yeah and I keep
telling her go get him do whatever get
new ones or take them out but get it
done because I do not want to deal with
that if she's I don't wanna you know
what I mean does anything like me the
chances are as soon as you stop telling
her to do it she'll do it on her own 100
100 fuck is that would you ever marry a
woman who would listen to you no
absolutely no no so
um so the only reason I now
defend myself against the plastic
surgery stuff is because when someone
says when you got a facelift when you
got cheek implants you're kind of
calling my mom ugly
why did you look like your mom well yeah
I look like my parents so someone's like
oh you got work done you're kind of
saying my mom and dad are ugly right you
know
does that make sense
um because my cheekbones are my mom's
okay oh I got everything yeah you know I
mean look you look like you you look
like you had work done here's two
reasons ready yeah yeah it's just your
look but I also Chris Rock said to me
once it's so funny he's changed my life
every time I like see him just in
passing he'll say something that'll just
change my life right and I don't know if
he I'm sure he knows he's doing it he
just like throws wisdom out in casual
small talk yeah you know he said to me
once when I first started getting quote
successful and I was like giving money
to family members trying to like fix
everything and help everyone help you
know and he was like so how much money
are you giving your family members now
and I was like it was like out of
nowhere and he knew yeah and um I'm like
how does he know how would he know like
an idiot and um I was like oh yeah and I
was like bragging about it I thought it
was such a good person I just got my mom
a car or whatever I got my aunt car I
gotta this and this like because I
really just want to make money to be
able to because we grew up with that
money and I just watch people stressing
out about money yeah it was just made I
thought it would fix everything and for
the people that say that money doesn't
buy you happiness didn't grow up fucking
poor yeah no it doesn't a lot of people
that say that shit you don't know what
it's like to be without and when you're
without it I think it's rich people who
say that it's people and and that I
think are born rich too yeah I think I
think yeah people don't want other
people to be rich said that money does
buy your happiness because it buys you
freedom and it buys you the ability to
not worry all the time fuck yeah I
became happy when I came in your house
I'm so happy you have money this house
makes me happy and I'm happy for you
thank you it's like beautiful so that's
it for Comics
what do you think on like Elaine Maxwell
now someone's like come stay with me
like yeah it was like Russell Peters is
like that too this is why I have that
and then we use that office for the
roast we wrote in my attic I'll show it
to you we turned into just like a big
writer's room
um not weirder than Harvey actresses
into hotels do the Chris Rock what
happened then he said um all right well
giving people money it's only a matter
of time before they start hating you
it's never alone it's always a gift
you don't loan it no because then it's
every time they see you they're like I
owe her money I fucking you know it's a
gift you owe me nothing back because
then I was like oh I don't want to give
that's patronizing like as if you know
it's like oh yeah you'll get me back
later you'll pay me back yeah yeah but
then just give it every time you see
them like are those new shoes okay you
know what I mean we're always there was
a score Chris said something to me too
once he said to me ten thousand dollars
and I was like what he said yeah you
have a cheat on your wife ten thousand
dollars
ten thousand bucks oh that's how much
it's gonna cost you that's how much
you're gonna cost the emotional cost
because
ten thousand dollars oh my God if I got
everything men think a lot about the
financial costs instead of the emotional
cost so I was with this this new dude
and we were trying to figure out he was
like oh do we take to go to Malibu where
my mom was dying I got an Airbnb on the
beach so she could just look at the
ocean
that's another day
um and it was like 40 minutes to go the
way that doesn't have like circuitous
nauseating turns all right let's pause
again you know what I mean if someone
could go back but you know what it means
circuitous no guess okay
squiggly
yes
so I think you're smart so if you
pretend you don't know what words mean
that I'm that I'm saying not that I
don't know you're insulting me you're
saying I'm dumb and I don't know who's
smart no please don't turn it on you
it's not that would be a circuitous
conversation move the security I'm not
saying I don't know what the word means
circuit I don't I've never guessed I've
never heard it and I've never used it
sure but I I love it it's like
unnecessary I love words I love it I
love it we talk for a living yeah
especially now you know podcast
um circuitous is a great word circuitous
there we go stay signed out longer than
the most direct way a router Journey
longer than the most direct way the
canal flowed a circuitous route this
podcast has been secured us well it's a
long time it's not the most direct it's
not boom it's
no they're not they're signing in
to hear a conversation between two
people and where it goes It goes I think
and like you know don't always tune out
if you're listening what's going on with
you uh if you don't like it like what's
going on with you if you like why are we
turning on these people I know they're
fucking amazing people but that's what
I'm saying it's like that's why it's the
it's that um
you know it's not the Damocles sword but
it's the absured mutual destruction of
like
I'm well read I'm gonna be yeah you're
right very well read I'm not I don't
read books here's the thing can I say
this also not about reading them it's
about when you read them if you don't
know a word are you gonna I I have to
start reading what I started doing with
my son I gave you a book today you gave
me a book today and I took it
um he actually at night we instead of uh
you know whatever watching TV will
actually sit in bed and read books
together now this is the book I gave you
that I love what is it about boom and
bust it's the global history of
financial bubbles okay basically about
friends is it gonna make me sad
is it gonna make me sad about what's
happening about to come and and we're
all gonna be like shit again I think
that Comics you know people that are
hypersensitive they're not just Comics
obviously they exist in every profession
it drives me nuts when people Define
humans by their jobs as if that means
anything as if all lawyers are fucking
assholes and all you know sex workers
are you know whatever I just don't like
the I just did something I don't like
but in the interest of Time Boom because
you need to Boom
boom we'll do it what
um boom being hypersensitive where am I
going with this
I'm with you but you gotta fucking you
should have the full banana you should
have fucking had that whole fucking
banana because I was with you I've been
with you the whole time I do take
Adderall I take it to sleep I thought it
keeps you up no so it does some people
so my Adderall thing is this yeah I take
five milligrams what does it do I was
prescribed Adderall to sleep so if you
truly have OCD it doesn't give you
energy it calms you okay so if you truly
have it what if you have ADD
ADHD that's what I meant ADHD I'm sorry
I also have OCD you have OCD but I don't
want to get rid of that what is it
what's your OCD well I think these terms
are all pathologizing superpowers and we
just don't have education systems or
work systems that allow people to thrive
Zak amico's wife actually works in
Montessori
um and the whole Montessori idea was
like kids gravitate towards what they're
interested in I love that and you go
with their stuff I want my I wish we had
that where I was I wish that was every
school had a version of that but people
learn differently and yeah you know and
so this like Whitney you're so OCD
you're so OCD it's like you might not
understand the process of what I'm doing
but it works for me and I thrive better
when anything most people do but we're
most people are you know working with
their hands tied behind their back for a
company they don't even believe in
helping build someone else's addiction
dream bullshit dream dick slash
addiction and so we're like all working
the same way and whereas you know so for
me I I say I have OCD but saying I don't
I'm glad I do I think it's a superpower
not a handicap not okay yeah you know
like being uh autistic as long as yeah I
mean I was diagnosed with autism when I
was a kid but
it's impossible to isolate variables
because also I would like to go back and
get
um tested for everything too I've never
been tested but all of the testing is
like yes that being said yeah all of
these tests are by human beings and
being tested inherently affects the way
you're going to behave in a way you know
a lot of people we want to so I used to
do focus groups that's how I paid for
things so two book girls that I did with
Michael Patrick King every episode was
about girls like make Broke Girls making
Morgan Murphy Morgan Murphy was on it
yes one of my favorite people in the
world most brilliant I I had the
privilege of um being able to con her
into working on Roseanne as well oh
really because I I actually well I
remember I do radio shows and I would
call in and I would have her write as
we're doing the show she would write for
me so I would say lines that she was
writing to be like to do radio
interviews Morgan is
almost too good like she's she's someone
who I'm like
uh being that good must be hard because
you took her away from me
yeah she was in New York you're right
and I she lived up the street and she
came out here for Kimmel actually I
fucking she's on Kimmel when I was
kidnapped yeah she's fuck she's I love
her so so very
like and she's thank God she spends a
lot of time at Doug Stanhope
and Norm she she's like a female Norm in
a way like that's how much I admire her
Talent yeah in a way that I I can't even
you you know when you see someone you're
like I could do that if I try really
hard I could do what that person's doing
but her I'm like her processing speed is
just like wild and so um anything people
like that we suffer the consequences
when we have a we're great at something
like I I know that I have a couple
natural things I'm really good at and it
makes people think I'm crazy sometimes
but like that's okay
um
the ones that mine don't matter and the
ones that matter don't mind you know
it's how to self-soothe out of that
um but I have lost my train of thought
but that doesn't mean we're not going to
go to a better place no and I don't I
think that I think that everybody's
crazy I'm crazy my crazy
I just think that word has I'm not I
don't say this word it's just there was
a time when we went from you've actually
told me not to say a few words but I
didn't see okay there was a time where
we said automobile and then now we say
car what was that year like where we
were switching over or to a better word
I think people still in England still
say automobile okay we left that place
for a reason because they were fucking
they wasted our time I don't think crazy
is a bad thing though when you look at
crazy it's been used for women as a very
bad word I I I I think crazy to me can
be can be I think it makes you look
unique unique would be great but I don't
think crazy I'm not in control of it or
it hurts other people yeah I don't I
don't like I'm fucking crazy I know I am
I know but also my crazy insane people
say that about myself has got me you
know who's crazy
I'm not crazy I'm not well I'm not crazy
person crazy is not a bad thing people
should call me crazy has got me to be
able to do what I love to do for a
living a woman is crazy we are saying we
are not like honoring their ancestral
trauma or superpowers it's a it's like a
dismissive way to say well oh she's just
crazy don't listen to her it's it's a
it's like this was what the female isn't
that isn't a male crazy just a murderer
isn't it that isn't like I think for men
too that guy's crazy he's a fucking
lunatic well murderers if you murdered
like you know there's certain people if
you murdered um your brother-in-law
because he was molesting your niece is
that guy crazy
I mean that's the fucking crazy yeah no
but I mean crazy I think you can go
crazy if you're pushed I think crazy for
men too you don't have that in us it's
bad but I mean it's bad you know I
understand what you're saying for women
but to me crazy is is not a is a is a
good thing
okay I think to me I think that most
people don't think that but it's like me
like I think identifying someone as
alcoholic or an addict is a compliment
because usually if our dopamine
receptors don't hold dopamine the same
way usually addicts are sorry I think
we're all addicted to something so I'm
not insulting anyone you might just be
addicted to things that are socially
acceptable instead of things that aren't
so all I think addicts that's a
compliment you're an addict like I'm my
addiction serves me like you know the
ones that I've chosen some of them used
to not serve me and I hope I have to
maintain that and they could come back
and fucking take over my life and make
my life unmanageable if I don't stay on
top of it and stay you know alert if I
don't atrophy my fucking brain with my
ego and get comfortable but I think that
like people can go crazy but I think the
idea of like just that guy's crazy or
that woman's crazy like I think you know
who got the shit end of this is like
orney Adams
like using words like that can like
really fuck up someone's life I think
like I think for me I was called crazy
so long by people that it really did
hurt my opportunities because people
were like oh she's crazy you know guys
when like I just that's what everyone
you know said about me and I had I think
I was I think I have been but I was like
never not doing the best but there's
certain like certain things about me
that people have said about me which
hurt but were true and I actually
adjusted it's I constructive criticism
how else adjusted you know what I mean
but it happened even with my interested
someone you trusted had to say it to you
or just anyone no because I'm for me
I'm always self-evaluating me I'm trying
to make me better I'm not trying I don't
care what you do yeah I don't care what
he does ornie Adams with this guy or
that but what if I'm near your kid I
don't well you're not gonna be near my
kid you know what I mean uh but what I'm
saying is like I'm always looking for me
trying to change me I'm not worried
about that person I may talk about that
person that person might affect me with
their shit but what is it about me it's
like same shit with my wife when I found
my wife my therapist and me don't talk
about my wife we don't talk about my
mother's problems we talk about what I
fucking did we're cleaning your barn
what cleaning up your own shit a hundred
percent my mother and me I I say this
all the time we stop fighting around 10
years ago when we were screaming at each
other on the phone as usual per our
relationship and then she whispered into
the microphone Bobby when are you gonna
realize I'm Never Gonna Change
and I went
oh I I I'm out I'm out surrender I'm not
playing the game anymore I'll fucking do
I'm Gonna Change I have to do what I do
you go be mom I get it
that's your life and then we don't fight
anymore I get my mom I understand her
and this is why the Serenity Prayer
being God grant me the serenity to
accept the things I cannot change the
courage to change the things I can right
the wisdom to know the difference yeah
so like the fucking kicker man like Oni
Adams it's like only yeah I understand I
love what I actually love only I've
always liked him I've known him my whole
career I knew him back in Boston I feel
similar to him in terms of the way that
I've been perceived like out of the gate
just kind of getting a little bit like
like you know growing up in public is
hard I got I think I got a little bit
forward-facing kind of early I think
that I'm one of a few people maybe
that'll admit this but I think I got a
couple opportunities as a girl before I
was ready you know I think people say
like women don't get opportunities in
comedy you know that's everything is two
things can be true at once I was
unfairly discriminate against of course
but I also you had to have a girl in the
lineup so I know I got on a couple shows
for a long time I didn't deserve to be
on and the main how the fuck can I say
something sure you keep talking about
this how do you you got what you got
because it was yours
you've got you you got because it was
yours
stop trying to figure out
why you got I didn't deserve it who who
the fuck I just got seen a little early
by The Gatekeepers didn't get seen early
you got seen at the time you got seen
and you were given what was yours I
never want anything I don't deserve you
deserved it it's my you got it because
it was yours 26 an hour special who the
fucking uh okay Michael Jackson got it
at 10. I used to say the same thing
about oh this fucking look at that look
at that this guy's got this right then I
realized one day right that's theirs
it's not mine I'm actually it's I'm
fucked up about what other people think
of me I'm fucked about other people's
stuff I'm about this and that dude why
that way that's yours that was your life
that's your path that your career those
are the things that were given to you so
you can go on your journey to where you
are right now the people I looked up to
I you're right and I defer to you
because you know more about comedy than
I do but the people I looked up to I
don't know about that put in yeah 10 15
years of road work does it matter I
listen I've been I've I have friends
that are very more
successful than me in the business
you're talking money and fame right
right
that's not mine
I had to realize and if I got that too
soon in the last three years I if I oh
last four years I'm trying to get what
you got right I'm trying to get what you
got and when I get what you got or what
Billy got or what Chappelle got oh Louie
then I I got I did it
and then I went wait a minute I I
already made it
I got it I think you're Rodney
Dangerfield I got it you know see what
I'm saying I got it I got it right now I
did it I'm doing comedy I have a job I
pay my bills I have my family I have
love I have friends
I'm fucking killing it the only thing
standing in your way right is
a tick in your asshole in my asshole
right the only thing that can stop you
the only thing that could stop me but I
think like for me you
um you
you did your shit you did your thing
I don't care I don't care fuck it this
guy over here uh he doesn't deserve that
he's not even funny
what's he so what's he supposed to do
what's that guy supposed to do he's
supposed to go well Bobby
doesn't think he's funny this guy
doesn't think he's funny and he's only
doing it for five years so I'm gonna
turn this down I'm gonna turn all this
down right now because these other
people don't think I do it
you
you showed up
for life
right you showed up for life and you you
were trying to do what you wanted to do
which is fucking great
because I look
I mean I accomplished all my goals like
what I always think to myself and I'm
sorry I'm getting emotional I just wish
my mom was alive to hear what you're
saying because to hear like I never knew
if she
knew like
like the only accomplishments that I
think of course love seeing me on the
Today Show and people talking about me
and stuff but like if she you know knew
that someone like you thought this like
she I know she'll know you know but um I
just wish she could have heard this and
I don't really say that or think I'd
never think that I never do a podcast
I'm like I wish Mom had heard that it's
the opposite I'm like I really hope she
doesn't listen to that
um but I'll just have to have trust that
she knew everything she knew and I just
I don't want her to think that all her
sacrifices were in vain and that me
being gone because I was gone so much
doing stand-ups and I was doing 80 80
CDs a year on the road colleges Monday
Tuesday Wednesday and then I go do go in
you know Tuesday night for radio
Wednesday morning and you know and uh
with the road kangaroo and the the
hooker whatever local you know beanie in
the honey badger yeah mad cow whatever
and so we we do press you know at
fucking 6 A.M and then we do Wednesday
through Sunday and start all over again
so I didn't see her that much but I was
trying to you know I I played for Keeps
with this thing you know and it was like
I knew it was like this is all in
there's no boyfriends there's no guys
there's no I didn't have dog like I
didn't have like I got a dog when I was
32. I was just like I was gone all the
time and um
you know when I finally earned enough
money to buy a house I didn't know how
houses no one taught me about money as a
kid right yeah I thought four 1K was a
marathon like I did a little bit about
that my first special I didn't know and
so I thought in order to have a house
if it was a 500 000 house I thought
you'd need 500 000 so I was working to
try to get you know no hey I did the
same thing so then I got a house
like thinking she would come move
to LA with me you know and then she had
the stroke like a couple days later and
um I found out that she didn't like have
any money you know and I didn't know
that like and I bought this fucking
house it's just it's just like kind of
just this like
um
Shakespearean Comedy of Errors
um yeah and uh yeah I guess all I wanted
to say was that um you know it's an
honor to hear you say that and I I don't
want anything I don't deserve and I
think what happened was I got a lot
very quote quickly yeah um and now I
just want to prove that I deserve it and
I I do with a smile on my face my heroes
carry strugg remember Carrie strugg she
was the Olympic gymnast who had the
broken ankle and in the Olympics to be
you know I believe was Russia it's
always Russia had to do a fucking dosey
doe this is the only time I don't know
big words fucking sport uh gymnastics
but I'm I'm following it perfectly she
had to do a bunch of flips and land and
she landed on the broken ankle it broke
it worse Perfect Ten smile on her
fucking face
and one yeah so for me mine is I don't
want any credit for what is the least
you can do because then what we do it's
this is when people are like I did three
shows I remember Louis CK actually
you know and I'm very defensive with
Lucy K because you know
he did what he did he you know it did we
we can forgive people we don't have to
free of their actions addiction makes
sense no I I defend him to that I'm just
playing defense for the people I just
might not yeah have come to the we
forgive others it's fine yeah when I
didn't forget people it's because I
needed to be right and I think right now
we're at a time where for the first time
in history we can put our opinions out
in public sure when we're feeling things
before they're facts we put out our
feelings and then we're too embarrassed
to change our minds or say we were wrong
so a lot of people I think have to stick
to what they thought when they were
under the influence of adrenaline oh
yeah no I don't I don't believe in that
at all so it's it's I but I think most
people haven't done well they said you
know don't apologize it's like well for
what not yeah I've said so much stupid
shit that I was wrong and then I evolved
you know what I mean but I think you I
really want to say this listen and you
know look I've I'm fucked up too I I've
I you know we all
I think we all in this business when you
see Fame and you see there's so much
stuff there's dreams can come true right
um and I feel like you know it's almost
like uh hitting the Mega Millions you
know uh so you know when you look at
other people's career we're always
looking that way we're always looking at
something else but what we have when you
can stop and just be
um
if you can be aware of where you're at
and the people in your life and you can
be grateful I really believe you've made
it and it doesn't matter you know you
know you know you getting what you got
when you got it to me at this stage of
my life and this goes for anybody is
yours it's yours
it's yours that's your path because if
you think that getting money or fame or
success
relieves you from struggle relieves you
from Pain relieves you from
relationships self-discovery uh feeling
bad being fucked up all that stuff
you're crazy and it by the way what it
did not trying to get sympathy yeah you
know it did it that money I'll take it
again and again both my parents had
Strokes without health insurance sure
the month both TV shows went into
production when he has two shows fuck
her whatever she suck dick to get ahead
who cares whatever still to this day
never have slept with one comic one
comedic actor wouldn't no not one
stand-up comic for some reason I knew
like I had a darwinian Instinct yeah do
not sleep with Comics I cannot give
people any more reason to think yeah
that I you know yeah I've never slept
with a comic either there's I mean and
there's nothing wrong with it I love
comics but I luckily just saw them as
brother yeah and I needed a family so
bad that I knew sex coming from sexual
abuse and stuff I just knew that would
fuck up the only place I felt safe which
was The Comedy Store which is when
people say The Comedy Store is toxic
that's fine you had a good childhood
good for you for me it's a warm hug
that's why I feel safe okay so when
people say women don't feel safe at The
Comedy Store okay well the fucking
hallway was Joe Rogan Brundage there's a
little MMA fighter shop like if you know
I mean I feel the safest there oh okay
when all my guys you know maybe not
Bobby Lee you know I love Bobby but I'd
probably bite an ankle
he'd fucking he'd taken Achilles out
with a tooth if it came down to it they
get smaller every time I see him maybe I
don't know maybe my under I think Bobby
would I I wouldn't mind Bobby on my side
like Rogan's wife is now such a good
friend of mine we never got to meet
because you know the the queens that
y'all picked probably don't want to hang
out at you know the Penguins you know so
I don't get to meet the wives very much
right and I feel I've always felt so
insecure that these wives must think I'm
flirting with their man or whatever oh
no no no I know but yeah they don't I
call I called my wife today I know
they're not threatened by me but no no
my wife actually likes you she actually
is always rough well no because my wife
doesn't fuck with comedy my wife doesn't
fuck with stand up at all she's not a
stand-up fan she loves me but she's you
know we don't we're not even following
each other on social media like my wife
is from the 50s like my wife when I said
to my wife
I work for your wife yeah I will be your
wife's fucking assistant any day she's
uh you know she's just that person but
when I said I was coming here today
ancestry and I I she's uh
everything but uh when I was coming in
today I said listen
her mom passed away you know I you know
I would like to I'm gonna go buy flowers
you know I want to get her flowers just
you know she goes she was like you yes
absolutely you go do that you know I
mean which I know like my wife
doesn't know you
but she knows you right and she knows
I'm coming over here but she's like yes
you need to go do that absolutely so how
lucky I know
whatever you're just the narrative is
you're the crazy whatever but how
awesome that she gets to be reminded
like this is the man I married
yeah you can talk to her about that I
would love for her to fucking but you
don't need
no like I think like I don't fuck around
my wife like I'll say oh you're gonna go
do some you're gonna go meet some like
she went last week away to go with her
friends and she you know had leather
pants on her hair was done and fucking I
was like what the fuck
I don't get I never got leather pants
and she I'm like you're going to fucking
love the pants because you go you're
going to fucking leather pants men babe
I go you're going to meet somebody she
and she gets sad she don't she's like I
don't like when you do that
and that makes me love her so much more
the truth because she gets sad she gets
mad not like like hey man yes I'm not
mad I'm disappointed it's like I fucking
I'm with you you bitch
I've been with you through all this shit
I've been with skinny Bobby fat Bobby
now skinny Bobby again and I'm a hot
bitch and why can't I dress like this to
just get attention I don't want I mean
she's like a seven
a New Hampshire
seven no she's in New Hampshire nice I
was gonna say no I'm kidding my wife
she's beautiful I'm so I'm so fucking
lucky you know what it is I think the
one thing I will say just on the subject
and I'm not being chastising or anything
but yeah when we've chosen our person
and they've chosen us when we insult
ourselves we insult their the choice
they made but I'm I fuck up because I'm
a comic but self-estabricating humor she
knows that but when we go I'm crazy I'm
a piece of shit one of the funniest
jokes I ever made was given by her I
actually said when I on one because I've
been fat six times
she's known five of the fats I've been
skinny fat skinny fat right
um and one of my fats is that run in
this you have to watch just watch
killbox as soon as you can he does a fat
round about all the different fats it's
beyond one of the facts I was in I said
to her I got mad at her because I was
getting ready to go out for the weekend
to go do spots of the cellar and I go
I'm like
I go to do fucking I go you shrunk my my
shirts
and she's like I didn't shrink your
shirts I go you shrunk them because they
don't fit and she goes did I shrink the
bed in the car too fatso
one of the greatest jokes
from her to me
that she wrote and I just did on stage
because if I could kill me I was like
you bitch when we did the burnt roast
you know you'll see it when it comes out
but you know
it is this amazing thing where you know
and I think that I'm getting there and
it's another conversation the guy in my
house uh Giannis was like why is there a
Romanian boy in your house does he so
I'll get to the guy in the house at some
point I'm sure there's a lot of
questions but I do think as Comics like
you know everyone needs a wife what I
needed away you know and it's like what
Leanne Chrysler oh my God and Burr like
bird Chrysler is brilliant hilarious
genius but none of this could happen no
without you couldn't be on tour you
couldn't be taking the risks you take
going to skank Fest without knowing that
your son is at home
I'm not funny without my wife
you know I'm not funny without her I'm
really not I am not
I think most of the comics I look at
because I've studied all your
trajectories in a way that's literally
creepy right and I've looked I've
studied like I studied when did they do
The Tonight Show what venues were they
doing I've looked I've looked up
everything and when I go to venues I
talk to every every sound guy I talk to
everyone I ask about everyone who I
admire and what they did yeah you know
and the managers we've had in the past
yeah whether we're still with them or
not they did have wisdom and asking the
door guys and asking I would ask I would
go to Boston when I was dating my friend
Nick Horizon now my best friend and I
would ask people at the comedy
connection I would ask about narduzzy
and and yeah you know I'll always say it
wrong and I'd ask what do they do how do
they do it did they see you and I would
ask and I would just study study study
comedy yeah and um and I do think that
when
a lot of male Comics that I've seen
going from hilarious
to oh that's a living legend is when
they found their yeah life partner I
didn't become funny until I I fell in
love with my wife
and I didn't become a man until I had my
son your relationship is a business
decision yeah my my wife
I was scared the whole time that if I
befell in love or committed or to
another human being I would lose I would
my funny and it was the exact opposite
and then I had the fucking bullshit myth
in my head
the disease may be justifying a way to
stay crazy I'll use that word for this
is if I get any mentally healthy or I'll
stop being funny a hundred percent oh my
God I gotta stay Broken You Gotta Stay
broken because if you're not broken
you're not edgy if you're not edgy you
lose your mojo when you're broken you're
really just looking for ATM card half
the day and you can't focus on stand up
yeah and the next thing is try the kid
for me
I never wanted one I know because I
never thought I could I never deserved
one I had the same dessert I just took
my ID out so please say yes yes here's
the thing
when I I said to my wife I want to have
a kid and she was like yes and now
I look at my son
and I
owe you fucking bitch
you broke me you bitch I ain't got to do
it I ain't gonna fuck I get weepy I look
at my son when he's sleeping
and and I I
I could cry I could look at my wife and
cry and I don't have no problem saying
that I look at my wife and the fucking
love I feel for that woman I tear up and
my son knows because he'll say Dad stop
what is it that we love people the most
when they're asleep
when you look at your kids sleeping it's
there's something
for me there's something I'm so fucking
happy reason why I got the surgery I
need to be around as much as I can can I
say something and I don't mean this to
be a luxury for you guys because you're
talking to someone I do certain things
I'll I now I for the most part like to
only speak on things I have an authority
to speak on and unfortunately
unfortunately I have the authority to
speak on having had to parent my own
parents they were both in hospital beds
and icus when I was 28 until 40 now yeah
and so they were so busy
trying to take care of me and they
didn't take care of themselves so the
way you take your body I say like if
you're even if you don't have a kid yet
it's future child abuse if you're
abusing your own body because they're
gonna have to look at you in a bed and
so when I see my friends they're like oh
it's fine they're smoking trust me I
smoke every now and then I love a
cigarette I trust me I want to do it all
too but every time you don't go to the
dentist then you have to you're not
going to the neurologist if you have
headaches you're not checked exercise
you're not taking care of yourself
you're just saying fuck you to your kid
and going your best years are going to
be in an ICU watching me drool
when when I decided a couple years ago
to do the surgery and then after I got
it and I told my wife I go it's your
turn now and you need to go to the
doctor everything get everything checked
out get those fucking tits fixed no I
know that there is no 100 she's actually
now she's taking her I go because it's
listening to your body don't listen to
doctors I said it's not fair to him
if we if he has to if his kids want to
fuck you because you're giant fake
titties if he has to if he has to take
care of us that stinks I go we have 20
something years I used to have a joke in
my ACT I have 30 Summers left
that's it I have 30 Summers left if you
get lime disease 30 if I do that levels
I don't have 10. well now what I'll say
is is Dr David Sinclair and I know a lot
of the New York Comics sort of roll
their eyes at La comics and I know it's
going to sound weird but David Sinclair
we don't anymore lifespan if you just
want to look into metformin of zempic
NAD nmn I know that the FDA didn't just
approve any d please always question the
fucking
FDA always always
um uh you know cannabis is was just
barely legal and people are trying to
overturn it now a lot of people make a
lot of money with us not having these
kind of miracle cures that are starting
to come around metformin uh the first
person that will live to 120 has been
born
I I want to say something about this if
you want to live longer I think but I
think you're right take care of yourself
that's a big thing for me and wife for
him is the worst thing is I want to go
back I think you should have a kid 100
because I adopt from Appalachia though I
don't give up your crisis because
there's nothing
I'm telling you right now I live the the
regret I have because I do I still want
to make money I still want to make
Freedom it's called I call it freedom I
want my wife because I want her to have
that house you understand like I want
her to have those things I want my kid
to have those things that I never had I
want so I do you know I'm still working
my ass off to get that
holy shit money to come in you know
um I'm happy we're all happy but I still
want that for her I want her to have
that fucking dream house you're gonna
get I just want to put this out there
manifest it you're gonna get so you know
Will Arnett yeah he um
uh this isn't I'm gonna be insulting but
he has that podcast smart list he's been
on ton he's has been the voice of GM yep
you know I know William Batman too right
funniest thing ever he's hilarious I
believe that's him but he was he's been
the voice of GM yeah just like the
progressive lady makes millions you know
you're like you're gonna do all the
respectable you know stuff that who
knows everything's changing now I'm
stand up and the Arenas and whatever you
want to do yeah but it's that
sort of
um voice of a big campaign that's just
that like Monopoly money that you'll
make in your sleep like I predict and
I'm
very rarely wrong
uh that you will get the voice of like
not the Energizer Bunny but like of the
new you will be
mermaids you'll be ZocDoc the app uh the
donut for Dunkin Donuts dude what is it
a dog fucking Duncan remember that SNL
yeah yeah yeah you know I'm not SNL you
know but anyways I want to say I want to
finish this thought yes that
um but all that beside I still want that
my wife the only thing that I work for
right
because I have fun I'm having fun now I
had fun tomorrow at Bert Show I'm in La
I'm Mike Carlton my number one best
friend blah but I can't wait to go home
and sit on the couch with my kid here
and my wife right there fucking I the
only thing I live for
yep 100 and it's like it's your pack
because like growing up that farm time
cleaning you don't want to clean up shit
but if it's your kid's shit yeah you
don't want to clean up puke when you see
it on the street but once your kids puke
you pull it up and look at it you know
so it's like it's taking me a long time
to go since we travel so much a baby
crying on a plane you're like I don't
want to have kids they're loud you're
like if it was my kid I wouldn't give a
shit and now if you hear a baby crying
on a plane you don't roll your eyes at
the parents you send them a glass of
wine and shut your fucking mouth I have
one lady on the plane with me with their
kid flipping out and I took the I go
listen your ears are popping I go she
grabbed a little thing of whiskey I go
go to the bathroom take a break I'll
watch your kid for a while and I sat
with this fucking kid I think a Dutch oh
I said I put it in the baby's mouth no
no no no no I'm just she went in the
bathroom and fucked on the gums got
fucking whacked out and I I mean 25
minutes she was in the bathroom and I'm
just sitting with this crying kid what
if she was sober 20 years I don't give a
fuck I I knew she was at a breaking
point and I just sat with this crying
kid smiling my face off because and
everybody hated me because I used to I
know I know you hate me but you know why
they're crying because the ears their
ears are probably they need gum or just
suck on something yeah I know because I
have a kid and I was in that position
and I get it and I don't get I got you
when I hear yes you can say why are you
flying a kid this young but you don't
know they could have a grandfather dying
that can't fly no I'm flying a kid I
want my kid out of this fucking country
and over to Europe and Aruba and fucking
uh Guatemala I want them out because I
want him to see the world so they don't
grow up like me fucking thinking in one
dimension that Medford Massachusetts is
the only place in the world and this is
how people are all over the place I'm a
little bit like maybe it's because I'm
preneurious with money
hilarious prenarius I mean can we we're
done we're done we have I'm not somebody
my sister's here okay we need eight
years is strange please go back I want
all the words get them and send them to
me because next time I come back on your
podcast I'm using them all panarius the
the the the eagle
Flipper the they're weapons that when
and I don't think you have to prove this
as much like I think is a as a sometimes
woman in the world people
I go to a auto body shop to get my car
fixed same problem yours has they'll
quote Me 2 000 they'll quote you 200.
you know what I mean yeah so as they
should why there's everyone's just
trying to survive that's where people do
desperate shit if you can get away with
it why not I'm a privileged white woman
I probably make more money than I should
have when someone tries to con me I kind
of I'm like yeah just trust me that
really sometimes maybe it'll change when
I have kids and I have a man that's
fully in but I'm fine with a little bit
of like yeah charge me extra you know
what I mean because a lot of the money
I'm getting is from some Saudi fucking
Corporation I you know what I mean so
it's about redistributing the wealth I
think that I'm at a point where it's
like how do we redistribute the wealth
responsibly no one wants to be given
money so you make them earn it always
but you're probably getting underpaid
he's probably getting underpaid most of
the time give me I'll fucking take money
or I'll stay here or you can go are you
sure that's how much it is you're just
doing that because you're a girl no guy
okay 500 and I go okay I'll give you 2
000 just because you told me the truth
listen to me
here I want you to do something
stop going to war
you know what kept me in the program
what is someone shared you know who you
are yeah why would you be listening he
went great he went you guys are here I
have good news I have bad news Old Timer
I wanted him to be my sponsor but men
can't sponsor women I would transition
just to have him be my sponsor you might
have good news bad news the good news is
the war is over yep and the bad news is
you lost yep
stop going to war
fucking this has been a lot of fun I'm
glad I got to know you I'm glad I got to
hang out with you and as long as it was
for public consumption yeah and here's
this I've had to pee
for around 45 minutes and I'm insulted
that you didn't just get up and do it I
didn't want to I was having fun that's
it's a good conversation you're edging
it's I'm edging this fucking this I I've
done a lot of these podcasts and
everyone's different everything is
different right it really is and I've
and I've I've thoroughly enjoyed let
going with it because in in trusting
yeah the type of person whose podcast
you go on if you're if your gut says no
I just don't and I don't have to know
why I I'm in a point in my life I
finally learned through my Al-Anon
program if my gut says this isn't right
I don't owe anyone an explanation of why
I could just say no you know in a way
that's graceful but
um the way that the star to be so
mercenary but so if someone goes and
watches you Rogan's not on YouTube
anymore so someone watches you on Andrew
Schultz podcast right yeah yeah my
preparation is I'll watch you on other
people's podcasts yeah to make sure I
don't ask you any of the same questions
because what's worse than someone asking
you a question you just had to answer
two days ago because when people are
looking up you after they see kill box
they're in a they're in a a fan is in a
wormhole of Bobby Kelly right they see
you on Schultz and then it says
recommended videos uh Bobby Kelly on
good for you and then they'll go to that
yeah and if you're saying the same shit
now you're a hack but it's the host's
fault because they didn't do the
research to see what questions you were
already asked no I always try to ask
questions that no one else asks I'm like
I'm like the complimentary to Rogan
you're gonna talk about war and elk and
and covid and I'm gonna talk about
feelings
well I mean Rogan that was you know
sometimes he'll just talk about bears he
talks about bears I'll talk about wolves
we talk about separate things different
animals right yeah you know so I always
just try to respect the audience and the
the comedian's time and just ask things
as long as they're not inappropriate and
anything can be cut out consensual only
I fucking don't you have to cut shit out
of this one unless you want to
think about it I am feeling peckish
oh I can help you with that big word I I
have lots of snacks downstairs
um why don't you go pee first
um uh kill box Robert Kelly
um I it's just if you don't watch this
just
I don't fuck with you
you know what I mean like if this is
just this is it this is like you know
people Everyone complaining there's woke
maroon comedy none of that's true yeah
Tucker Carlson and the journalist that
you fucking threw out of the bus by
having her text all of us and say the
comedy was dead it's never been better
the greats have never been better
they're out of the pandemic and they're
fucking have had kids the funniest
people on the planet have had kids yeah
and so now they're even fucking at
another level and you're watching the
living legend
um uh and uh I can't I'm jealous that
you haven't seen it and I I'm jealous of
someone that hasn't seen it yet and gets
to watch it for the first time
that was perfect that was fucking good
don't ride elephants I end these very
awkwardly
[Music]